figureau lie bonjour il est 9h et nous
allons vivre aujourd'hui le défilé du 14
juillet pendant plus de trois heures on
vous fera suivre ce grand événement avec
nos invités et tout d'abord nous sommes
en plateau avec nicolas barotte
correspondant défense figaro bonjour
nicolas n'hésitez pas pendant tout au
long de cela il va nous poser vos
questions on essaiera d'y répondre au
mieux comme d'habitude mais d'abord on
va aller sur place sur place retrouver
nos deux équipes tout d'abord timothée
d'hellemmes qui se retrouve avec raphaël
la drague timothée vous êtes sur les
champs-elysées expliquez-nous un peu
quelle est l'ambiance qu'est ce que vous
avez vu depuis que vous êtes arrivé ce
matin
oui vincent absolument nous sommes
actuellement au niveau de la place
clemenceau c'est-à-dire un angle entre
l'avenue winston churchill et les champs
elysées beaucoup de noms de ici vous le
voyez peut-être derrière dr ces images
les barrières de sécurité qui ont bien
sûr été installée une foule qui s'est
amassée derrière ces barrières une foule
qui est arrivé très tôt ce matin dès
6h30 ils avaient déjà les premières
personnes qui ont commencé à arriver
nous en ce qui nous concerne nous sommes
arrivés à 7h30 il a fallu passer
plusieurs barrières de sécurité
évidemment gros dispositif douze mille
policiers gendarmes et pompiers déployés
aujourd'hui est donc un premier une
première barrière de sécurité où il a
fallu montrer les billets les tickets
puisque les personnes qui se trouvent au
niveau de la place clemenceau sont des
personnes qui ont bénéficié de ticket
d'invitation il a donc fallu montrer ses
billets et ensuite une fouille une
fouille avec palpation évidemment pour
voilà un nouveau un nouveau contrôle et
nous en ce qui nous concerne nous avons
ensuite passé un contrôle de déminage
avec des chiens qui sont venus sentir un
petit peu de matériel et donc il a fallu
une grosse heure une heure une heure et
demie pour pouvoir accéder ici sur place
le défilé qui se prépare dans une
ambiance très calme très bon enfant
c'est une ambiance assez familial
beaucoup de noms des jeunes des
personnes un peu plus âgé et une
ambiance vraiment vraiment assez calme
les gens ici ont hâte que le défilé
débute réellement les troupes qui
commencent à se préparer dès lors vous
le voyez peut-être derrière moi un
command car là qui passe à l'instant au
niveau des champs elysées et des troupes
qui sont qui se trouve à peut-être 200
mètres de nous et qui se préparent
maintenant pour le début du défilé qui
est attendu d'ici une grosse demi heure
maintenant
effectivement merci timothée d'avoir
être d'être avec vous de suivre ce
défilé on va maintenant aller du côté de
julien leclercq julien leclercq qui se
trouve actuellement sur la base aérienne
de villacoublay
julien quel est votre programme
aujourd'hui pour ce 14 juillet
effectivement bonjour un sens je me
trouve à la base aérienne 107 vous
pouvez le voir derrière moi les
hélicoptères de la gendarmerie se trouve
ici alors à 9h45 nous avons prévu une
interview avec le général emmanuel josse
qui a été nommé il ya deux ans juste
après le 14 juillet 2020 et puis l'idée
c'est de pouvoir prendre pour vous des
images du défilé depuis les airs en
partant de cette base aérienne 107 qui
se trouvent effectivement dans les
yvelines en ile-de-france
regardera vers vous et merci en tout cas
d'avoir être d'être avec nous et on
voudrait nous un nouveau contrat on
essaiera de vous prenons direct aussi
pendant que vous survolez la capitale si
c'est possible si les moyens techniques
le le permettent on l'espère en tout cas
nicolas je me tourne vers vous
maintenant vous suivez les questions de
défense pour le figaro depuis un moment
qu'est ce qui change aujourd'hui par
rapport à l'an dernier pour l'armée en
france pourquoi ce 14 juillet différent
par rapport à un autre déjà il ya un
retour à la normale complet sûr puisque
l'accueil sanitaire est passé même si un
rebond épidémique on est revenu à des
jauges importante avec six mille trois
cents militaires qui vont défiler
quasiment 5000 à pied ouais et on
revient à un message
très important pour les armées qui tient
aussi au contexte on sait que la guerre
est revenu en europe avec le conflit en
ukraine depuis février donc ça ça change
forcément le sens de ce 14 juillet
l'année dernière les militaires d'isère
on va défiler un peu comme à la guerre
pour mettre en scène leurs engagements
soient procès l'eau le vent ou ailleurs
mais là aujourd'hui c'est un peu
différent parce que de la guerre est de
retour et dont il faut le prendre en
compte et c'est un peu le message qu'il
ya derrière ce mot d'or un peu marketing
partagée de la flamme qui tient aussi à
la cohésion nationale il faut mettre en
scène est ce que ceux ci un ressort de
la guerre la cohérence nationale il peut
partager la flamme partager la flamme il
ya aussi l'union européenne et l'otan
dans cette affiche c'est aussi un
élément très important absolument c'est
une nouveauté c'est que ça assez peu mis
en valeur mais ça serait les logos sur
les visuels cette cérémonie on voit
apparaître les logos de l'union
européenne et de l'otan et continue de
l'histoire de la france c'est assez
notable en fait est effectivement en
début de défilé ce sont les nations
européennes du flanc est les neuf
nations pays baltes bulgarie roumanie
pologne hongrie slovaquie qui vont
défiler sont toutes les autres qui sont
en première ligne face à la russie et
c'est là où le temps à céret engagé
depuis loin de février dont il ya une
volonté de replacer la france
parmi ses alliés dans des coalitions
alors qu'auparavant la france va défiler
un peu seul c'est vrai et là une volonté
de mettre en scène cette ses alliances
cette coalition effectivement est ce que
c'est quelque chose de spécial de voir
défiler des forces étrangères au sein de
dévier du 14 juillet il ya souvent une
nation des nations qui sont qui sont
invités puis les allemands l'année
dernière c'était des les forces
spéciales européennes dans takouba mais
ses forces spéciales européennes elles
étaient insérées dans une mission qui
était calme française c'est barkan oh
celle là c'est un peu différent parce
que il ya le drapeau de l'otan qui
chapote le l'ensemble de ses engagements
donc on met à l'honneur les nations qui
qui se défendent qui font de la
réassurance ou le flanc s mais elles ne
sont pas engagés avec la france aux
remises en estonie et en roumanie où là
nous sommes engagés dans les autres pays
c'est le temps qui est présent
effectivement le temps qui est présent
on voit en ce moment les images des
champs-elysées que vous pouvez voir sur
les images de la fp
il ya aussi d'autres d'autres questions
qui se posent il ya la question hier le
emmanuel macron était devant les armées
il a parlé de beaucoup de sujets
différents qu est-ce que selon vous il
faut retenir de ce discours
effectivement la veille du 14 juillet
présidente khadija fait une réception à
l'hôtel de brienne donc au ministre des
armées pour recevoir donc les unités qui
vont qui vont défiler et aussi pour
prendre du temps avec les familles des
soldats blessés et les familles
endeuillées serment que très important
pour les premiers militaires son art de
reconnaissance c'est important que que
ça existe ils en profitent le président
pour souvent faire un discours d une
feuille de route ça fait très politique
on se souvient qu'en 2017 il avait
humilié le général de villiers en public
bon c'était exceptionnel en temps normal
il donne quelques indications sur la
feuille de route des militaires pour
l'année à venir donc hier il a donné
plusieurs plusieurs messages il a
insisté sur justement s'est écoulé dans
la force morale sembas monk est revenu
plusieurs fois qu'on retrouve aussi dans
les écrits de l'état major pour préparer
l'arrière en cas de crise c'est le
premier message avec une île derrière
qui de relancer le sn eu le service
universel car un projet qui tient à
coeur au président mais dont les armées
ne veulent pas trop parce que elles
craignent une surcharge de travail
rappelle sont déjà engagés dans
différentes missions mais il leur a dit
je tente de vous que vous fassiez
davantage pour la république parce que
les armées sont censés être sorte
d'exemple de cohésion et après ils en
avaient plusieurs messages aussi sur le
retrait français du sel avec une attente
d'un nouveau dispositif pour l'automne
il a fait des annonces aussi sur le
budget en disant qu'une nouvelle loi de
programmation militaire à partir de 2003
jusqu'en 2030 oui parce que le budget
c'est toujours un peu mal comme toujours
le nerf de la guerre il ya eu justement
un rapport de l'institut montaigne dont
vous parlez donc vous avez eu
l'exclusivité qui demandait de comment
dire de se mettre à niveau on va dire
mais bien sûr c'est de revoir compte
tenu du contexte stratégique global
c'est que on a parlé de l'ukraine honda
a mentionné le sel mais plus largement
il ya aussi un de pacifique où beaucoup
se passe il retrait américain
d'afghanistan donc beaucoup de choses se
sont passées depuis un an et il est
important pour la france et pour pour
ses armées hia de repenser sa stratégie
globale et son dispositif est de mettre
en adéquation ses ambitions et ses
moyens à la retraite depuis cinq ans le
budget des armées a progressé
régulièrement internet milliards d'euros
par an 3 milliards l'année prochaine
dont c'est un effort qui est conséquent
qui a été tenue c'est rare mais compte
tenu des menaces qui existent
aujourd'hui et de nos ambitions toute la
france c'est pas suffisant c'est ce que
dit le rapport de l'institut montaigne
c'est qu'il faut ajuster ajuster les
forts note qu on va faire un peu plus
dans un contexte d'inflation ou tout
l'argent supplémentaire est rogné par
l'impressionnant c'est extrêmement
difficile c'est extrêmement difficile il
devra faire des choix est ce qu'il ya
des projets qui devront être davantage
soutenu d'autres qui devront être un
petit peu retardé pour justement dégage
du crédit pour autre chose cela demande
une réflexion et c'est ce qu'a dit pas
ce que recommande la soutient montaigne
et ça c'est ce qui a encore dit le
président hier maintenant il faut
réfléchir enfin des composants d'ici la
fin de l'année pour avoir une
programmation entre 2023 et 2030 pour
non seulement à réparer des armées mais
aussi les préparer à des crises qui
peuvent être extrêmement grave parce que
le contexte actuel forcément avec
l'ukraine et aussi avec le retrait des
forces au mali change complètement bien
sûr bien sûr c'est une bascule avec une
volonté être un peu moins présent en
première ligne en afrique puisque on
sent bien que voilà la france et il
n'est plus trop la bienvenue donc faudra
se mettre en retrait face étaient
présents parce qu'elle trouve un nas
terroriste et il faut aussi maintenant
se porter vers la question russe parce
que font sur du moyen terme il ya
beaucoup d'incertitudes sur ce que fera
la russie dans quelques années
objectivement rien rien ne lie si ça se
passe mal en ukraine la russie ne
dessine pas de faire davantage d'aller
plus loin donc ils vont il faut se
préparer et donc si ça part et ça veut
dire entraîné les militaires ça veut
dire lors de des équipements nécessaires
ça veut dire travailler en coalition
donc ça demande du temps de l'argent et
dans la fiction alors on va retrouver
revenir un peu sur les seuls sur le sur
le sahel aussi mais avant on va
retrouver timothée timothée d'hellemmes
qui se trouve actuellement sur les sur
les champs-elysées thimoté vous êtes sur
les champs-elysées vous êtes avec un
spectateur je crois est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire un peu voilà quelle est
l'ambiance que pourquoi il est venu ici
par exemple
oui vincent absolument je suis avec
thomas étudiant en droit à paris à
thomas qui est venu ce matin pour pour
vous c'était important de venir assister
à ce défilé du 14-juillet important est
plaisant oui on sent quand même de deux
années de confinement de christiane iter
je pense que les français sont heureux
d'être là pouvoir assister à un beau
monument national c'est un événement
mais un monument c'est
le soft power france est aussi le hard
power mais surtout le soft power
français je me souviens il ya quelques
années on avait de nombreux chefs d'état
notamment le président américain trump
qui était venu ici et qui avait trouvé
absolument fantastique une telle
démonstration de force de savoir faire
de l'industrie française et il s'en
était inspiré notamment pour la fête
nationale le 4 juillet la fête nationale
américaine quand je pense
qu'effectivement c'est un très bon
moment beaucoup de gens sont heureux
d'être là y fait beau pas trop chaud -
qui hier en tout cas qu'on puis c'est
important pour moi et mes amis également
et qu'elle est peut-être le moment que
vous attendez le plus ce matin vous êtes
venus pour voir vraiment les militaires
défilent et peut-être pour apercevoir
aussi le chef de l'état oui les
militaires le chef de l'état je pense
que ce qu'on aime aussi beaucoup c'est
quand la patrouille de france elle
défile dans le ciel avec une couleur
nationale que le président évidemment on
a tous envie de faire de le saluer du
phare contenu c'est toujours un moment
sympathique et puis encore une fois je
pense que c'est important pour les
français de se retrouver autour de
symboles surtout être le contexte actuel
donc donc voilà plutôt satisfait
racontez nous un petit peu comment s'est
passée l'ambiance vous ce que vous avez
vu depuis vous êtes arrivé combien de
temps déjà est ce que vous avez mis pour
pouvoir accéder ici sur les
champs-elysées parce que c'est un gros
dispositif de sécurité évidemment qui
est mise en place un dispositif de
sécurité certes mais qui n'est pas non
plus oppressant où ou laborieux a
traversé personnellement je viens de
convention donc on a pu prendre un
chauffeur jusqu'aux invalides ensuite on
a pu marcher on avait quelques
checkpoint jeu mais ça c'est plutôt très
bien passée c'était rapide on a été
fouillée évidemment contrôles d'identité
donc rien de bien particulier à signaler
à ce niveau là vous êtes venu donc entre
amis c'est ça exactement entre amis
profiter de cette matinée grâce à
l'invitation d'un contact voilà vincent
donc pour cette ce spectateur thomas qui
est donc venu effectivement ils sont
venus à plusieurs à plusieurs amis là
ils attendent donc impatiemment le début
du défilé qui est attendu d'ici une
petite demi heure maintenant merci
timothée effectivement merci vous le
dites si vous trouvez d'autres
spectateurs qui veulent vous parlez on
n'hésitera pas à revenir vers vous je
salue beaucoup de commentaires qui
arrivent des antho qui nous dit bonjour
alex healy vive notre armée malachy
qu'une joyeuse fête nationale celle
d'australie mari qui me dit bonjour
d'australie aussi alex
qui guy nouveau dit bonjour on en parle
alors deux personnes qui te regardent
d'australie et ça me permet de rebondir
sur ce que disait 7,7 intervenants se
passe ans et c'est le soft power la
française de 14 juillet ça reste un
événement et on n'y a pas beaucoup de
pays qui font ce genre de choses non
mais il ya peu de pays dans le monde qui
ont une armée qui est capable de venir
dans plusieurs théâtres de mener des
opérations c'est en réalité
hormis les américains les russes
tchèques ont d énormes armée en europe
britannique avant qu'ils ne quittent
union européenne et la france
les automobiles n'ont pas cette culture
militan cette capacité là mais français
sont capables dans la vue en roumanie de
réagir très vite pour envoyer des
personnels très rapidement se déployer
sur passe en roumanie pour en une
semaine
installé à caen et donc assumer une
mission de réassurance c'est un peu un
infâme de l'otan aujourd'hui c'est vrai
que il ya la collision très bien mais
quand il faut la faire fonctionner il ya
une question de rapidité et leur
activité très importante et c'est un des
enjeux du sommet de l'otan des joueurs
dernier qui était de refaire fonctionner
et de remettre sur la table cette
question de la préparation pour pouvoir
en cas de crise réagir très vite que
c'est bien beau de dire on est trente
pays alliés 32 bientôt avec la finlande
et la suède mais il faut pouvoir être
capable de répondre à une menace si elle
se pose chez un des pays membres assez
rapidement alors vous voyez sur ces
images on est dans la base aérienne de
villacoublay notre journaliste julien
leclercq et sur place il ya le briefing
en ce moment alors je sais pas si on si
on peut si on peut l'écouter mais en
tout cas voilà ce
alors effectivement vous dire horrifique
on va pas pouvoir en temps ce qui est
dit mais par contre là vous voyez
comment ça se passe il ya une vraie
préparation aussi pour ses forces armées
le 14 juillet c'est aussi ça fait mal
mais c'est leur fête c'est le moment où
il se montre et on voit que l'armée
montrent de quoi elle est capable et
c'est une démonstration de force qu'on
peut le dire oui puis c'est une
technique c'est un défilé aérien c'est
extrêmement compliqué ça que ça demande
à un timing
millimétré pour passer exactement au bon
moment à la bonne vitesse aux tunisiens
élisent et se demandent beaucoup
beaucoup d'entraînements préparation et
des répétitions il ya plus tard péter
qui sauf qu'ils se font en amont pour
les aviateurs pour les personnels euros
soit pour corps et tout ça il faut pas
sous-estimer les difficultés avec une
mention particulière pour cette année il
ya un rippeur qui va qui va défiler
aussi à la fin du défilé aérien c'est
merci c'est très important juste jeu
parce que vous le voyez sur ces images
gabrielat talent qui arrivent tous les
membres du gouvernement qui arrivent les
uns après les autres ça c'est aussi une
tradition on a eu françois braun on a vu
christophe béchu on a vu olivier ferrand
pap ndiaye c'est aussi la tradition que
tous les membres du gouvernement
assistent des fils que je suis bien sûr
c'est il ya tous les membres du
gouvernement toutes les autorités
françaises qui sont et qui sont conviés
ce et c'est au moment de solennité voilà
ce qu affronte enfants le par exemple le
nouveau ministre des armées sébastien
lecornu on va parler des relations entre
macro à l'armée qui avait pas très bien
commencé mon avis en 2007 est ce que
vous pouvez nous rappeler ce qui s'est
passé et comment ça a évolué depuis
alors ça a bien évolué et plutôt fermé
sacre au début c'était compliqué parce
que
madame acron jeune président arrivant a
voulu me faire des démarques d'autorité
il assure je l autorité chem est vrai
que au début du précédent quinquennat
une interrogation et non sur le budget
des armées et mal de villiers avait très
clairement dit non et des termes
extrêmement fleury ne sera pas faire et
cette phrase est sorti publiquement et
le programme amal prix et donc à avait
déclaré donc le 13 juillet 2017 c'est
moi votre chef devant devant l'état
major qui l'a très mal pris et donc
général a démissionné donc ça sera écrit
un peu de doute sur qui n'ont ce
président comment se comportent-ils il
humilie achète bien après traitement ça
s'est mieux passé pourquoi parce que le
président a mis de l'argent sur la table
c'est qu'il a donc décidé de loi de
programmation militaire 19-25 avec des
augmentations régulières
il a fait attention aussi à ces à ses
propos pour être moins directe marquer
plus d'attention dans ça plutôt bien
bien évolué et le changement de
gouvernement et la domination de
sébastien lecornu peu plus de liant
parce que florence paradis était une
technicienne travailler ses dossiers
mais elle de travers le contact humain
sébastien lecornu c'est un pur politique
et donc lui ce qu'il aime c'est aller au
contact des gens discuter donc il a ce
sens un peu humain et les mineurs y sont
sensibles
puis c'est un ancien réserviste il dit
oui les résistants quid ancien
réserviste il a une vraie fibre
militaire c'est que il avait pensé
s'engager quand il était plus jeune
sinon qu'il a été réserviste il y là il
a une sincérité ce n'est pas lui un
expert de la chose militaire mais tout
cas il a une sensibilité et les soldats
les maîtresses entraîne soucieux quand
même qu'on respecte leur singularité
comme ils disent leur spécificité c'est
pas un métier comme comme les autres
dire que il faut risquer sa vie il vous
faut être capable de prendre celle des
autres ce qui n'est quand même pas rien
ce qui est très très dur et il faut être
disponible en tout lieu et en tout temps
c'est beaucoup de contraintes beaucoup
d'exigence et c'est bien que aussi les
autorités et la nation en ait conscience
et sans un peu reconnaissant pour votre
effort qui est fait par par ces
militaires il ya encore beaucoup de
sujets à aborder par exemple hier le
président a aussi parlé du retour du psn
eu la cdu qui était une promesse de
campagne conté qui avait été lancé qui
était un peu mis sur pause on peut dire
pendant la pause pendant la crise
sanitaire et qui va être redéployé c'est
ça c'est donc c'est à une idée c'est
sympa marronnier qu'anne eux depuis la
fin du sens militaire souvent les
politiques se disent à ce sera bien se
retrouver un moment de cohésion
nationale pour former la jeunesse donne
un peu dallas est extrêmement dur de de
trouver un moment comme ceux comme celui
ci alors que pendant trois décennies il
n'y a pas de menace qui justifiait aussi
qu'on ait une mobilisation de la
notation de chaque génération le sns
adéquat c'était prendre un peu de temps
pour les premiers jeunes pour se former
à mi chemin entre les knicks nationale
mais aussi les armées avec paris des
suites de formation
d'information si aux premiers secours
toutes sortes de choses c'est très bien
mettre en oeuvre pour quoi parce que sa
demande d'une des moyens humains pour
encadrer ces jeunes et des blocs ou tout
simplement pour les accueillir et les
armes et ne veulent pas être les avez
participé sur leur dis venez passer une
demi-journée une heure pour présenter ce
que vous faites très bien mais elle n'a
pas organisé le vsn youtube parce
qu'elles ne sont plus dimensionné pour
pouvoir le faire
mais ce projet tient à coeur au
président donc il a remis à l'agenda qui
a redit très clairement à son ministre
c'est une priorité et ce quelque chose
qu'il faut mettre en oeuvre qu'il attend
des propositions dès cet été de la part
de la secrétaire et à sarah l irish
d'ailleurs attaché aux deux ministères
et des caisses nationales et est armé
pour pouvoir relancer le déploiement de
se mettre à nu qui avait été mis sur
pause comme vous dites sur pendant les
haricots vide parce que lyon prépare à
faire de rassemblement tout simplement
c'était une évidence mais maintenant il
faudra mettre des moyens et se trouver
du sens à ce et thank you parce qu'on
veut pas juste se dire maintenant on met
quelques jeunes ensemble pendant
quelques jours et voilà il faut trouver
une raison une justification pour que
les gens adhèrent aussi à ce projet il
trouve insensé et à l'interaction donc
on verra bien comment ça évolution on a
un peu pris par le temps parce que là on
voit tout ce qui se passe et c'est très
intéressant on voit les différents
gérald darmanin qui vient d'arriver mise
de l'intérieur on a vu il pourrait
timide justice juste avant en compagnie
d'olivier veyrat on parlait tout à
l'heure tu es des drones les drones
reaper c'est la première fois donc il va
il va défiler on va dire et sans pilote
du coup donc vous pouvez nous expliquer
pourquoi est ce que c'est devenu quelque
chose de très important pour l'armée ses
droits les drones donc qui sont déployés
au sel donc vous contrôlez les groupes
terroristes c'est devenu l'âme principal
de lutte contre contre ig mondialistes
pourquoi parce que on peut survoler une
zone pendant des heures et des heures
avec du renseignement
humain tout mixé star a permis de
détecter aussi une cible et comme c'est
drôle maintenant son armée depuis
quasiment deux ans maintenant bien on
peut frapper la cible quand on l'a
déterminé m et donc ça c'est un
instrument qui est incroyable pour les
pros les militaires qui marche très bien
en cfa sera beaucoup plus compliqué dans
d'autres théâtres en face à la russie on
ne pourra pas faire la même chose mais
au sel c'est très utile et c'est devenu
la principale pour lutter contre les
groupes terroristes et ça si on a eu
beaucoup de retard en france sur les
soirées drôle parce que pendant des
années on n'a pas voulu on n'a pas voulu
les armées pour des raisons politiques
on ne craint de perdre le contrôle donc
maintenant on cherche à rattraper le
retard n'a encore assez peu de peu de
moyens dans ces gros drones reaper
604 de survoler pendant des heures on a
donc très peu et maintenant il faut
aussi toute la gamme des drones étaient
calées les plus petits drones convoi en
ukraine et par hectare tueur que c'est
un plus petit format mais c'est très
utile parce que ça permet de faire la
guerre sans mettre la vie des hommes
rodrigue pas sur le terrain ça ne
remplace pas l'avion de la chasse parce
que la chasse à une fulgurante une
rapidité que n'a pas le drone mais les
deux sont très complémentaires
effectivement merci beaucoup nicolas on
va aller voir timothée timothée qui se
retrouvent tous ceux qui se trouvent
toujours sur les champs-elysées timothée
est ce que l'ambiance monte un peu est
ce que les gens se préparent à ce défilé
qui va démarrer d'ici une petite
vingtaine de minutes a priori
petite vingtaine de minutes way vincent
en tout cas ici l'ambiance l'ambiance
civilisé qui reste comme je vous le dit
tout à l'heure très paisible très très
détendue les gens qui rigole qui sourit
qui discutent entre eux en tous les cas
les gens qui arrivent de plus en plus là
on voit que ça c'est nettement nettement
gonflés là ses dernières minutes de plus
en plus de monde derrière les barrières
de plus en plus de journalistes
également ici pour ce qui est du du
pouldu plus journaliste on sent que ça y
est là on est à quelques minutes du
début du défilé on entend également la
fanfare derrière peut-être les derniers
les dernier échauffement et dans les
entraînements et puis certains commandes
car qui passe de temps en temps des des
véhicules également de gendarmerie de
policiers qui passe voilà le défilé qui
ne va plus tarder maintenant nous nous
sommes place clemenceau à quelques
mètres vraiment de l'elysée et les gens
ici nous confient qu'ils attendent pour
beaucoup de devoir passer le le
président de la république en tous les
cas voilà les troupes qui vont plus
tarder à un défilé est maintenant
certain certains ici portent le masque
d'autres d'autres pans tous les cas une
ambiance voilà détendu et les gens
attendent impatients maintenant le début
du défilé qui devrait arriver d'ici
quinze minutes à peu près
très bien merci beaucoup timothée on va
peut-être juste montré des images de
vélizy avec julien leclercq qui se
trouve actuellement dans l'est dans les
hangars pour voir les copains alors
qu'il est en train de bouger à ce moment
là dommage on vous remet on fera ça un
peu plus tard en tout cas merci nicolas
d'avoir été avec nous vos mots on vous
retrouve un peu plus tard dans la france
des filets pour me dire un peu ce que
vous avez retenu merci à vous en tout
cas et on va vous proposer en attendant
un petit reportage un reportage de
timothée de là mais rappelle l'adresse
que vous avez vu tout à l'heure ils ont
embarqué au bord de l'un des 12
hélicoptères de l'aviation légère de
l'armée de terre au départ de
l'aérodrome de chartres pour surveiller
champs elysées je vous laisse découvrir
ça
bonjour à tous nous sommes lundi 11
juillet il est 10 heures du matin nous
sommes à l'aérodrome de chartres dans
l'eure à un peu plus de 80 km de paris
et plus précisément de l'arc de triomphe
des champs elysées c'est là que vont
défiler les troupes militaires
françaises pour le défilé du 14 juillet
aujourd'hui pour figaro live nous allons
participer à la répétition générale de
ce défilé et nous allons donc prendre
part à bord de l'un des 12 hélicoptères
de l'aviation légère de l'armée de terre
française
au programme rapide brief sécurité et
rapide grève sur les conditions de météo
qui ont l'art excellente aujourd'hui
rencontre avec les pilotes l'équipage et
deux heures de vol au dessus de paris je
vous propose de vivre cette journée avec
nous c'est parti
[Musique]
ça plus à tenter le passage de pop à
cinq je vous confirme les oreilles à la
tribune présidentielle papa 2 c'est
l'arc de triomphe et dans l'articulation
force des régiments écouteurs de combat
donc le caïman poker 43 et le au centre
de paris et ensuite si vous avez une
panne du module charbon et ie8
avant de l'ouvrir nautique la carte
temps ci contre
et
[Musique]
donc là le bruit vient de se terminer
nous on va embarquer à bord d'un puma le
puma c'est un hélicoptère de manoeuvre
et dassault qui est surtout utilisée sur
le territoire national on va aller
rencontrer notre commandant de bord
bonjour dedans colonel bonjour merci
beaucoup de nous accueillir est-ce que
vous pouvez nous nous présenter un petit
peu cet engin ce puma écoutez c'est un
hélicoptère puma c'est ce qu'on appelle
un hélicoptère de manoeuvre et dassault
un hélicoptère qui a pour vocation de
transporter du personnel en général une
dizaine de personnes mais c'est assez
variable c'est un hélicoptère
relativement anciens et d'être des
années 60 c'est un hélicoptère de combat
dans le sens où il a vocation à être
engagée au plus près de l'action mais ce
n'est pas un hélicoptère de ce qu'on
appelle des hélicoptères armés c'est à
dire qu'il n'a pas pour vocation d'être
armé et de délivrer des munitions de
délivrer le feu au sol voilà sa fonction
de combat et de transporter et d'insérer
ou d'extraire des commandos au plus près
de l'action alors là on est en train
d'être interrompue parce que justement
il ya le plein qui est en train d'être
fait juste avant le vol je vous laisse
ce peut-être nous raconte nous expliquer
ce qu'ils sont en train de faire
précisément bien coûter pour aller
défiler il nous faut du kérosène donc il
faut mettre du kérosène est assez de
kérosène pour pouvoir défiler et prévoir
tous les temps d'attentes qui sont
nécessaires donc on fait un plein qui
est calculée en fonction de la masse
emporté du temps de vol dont on a besoin
et c'est pour ça que les pleins sont
faits au dernier moment pour qu'il
corresponde à la mission alors on est à
quelques minutes du décollage on va
rencontrer le chef de corps du 1er
régiment d'hélicoptères de combat
bonjour le bonjour colonel
pourquoi c'est important de faire une
répétition grandeur nature comme ça
trois jours avant avant l'événement ben
écoutez
le rendez vous d'un régiment qui
défilent le 14 juillet devant la
population française devant le présent
la république ça manque est important
donc on veut que ce soit beau ce soit
une réussite et c'est ce qui justifie
qu'on s'y prépare sérieusement avec
rigueur et c'est vraiment une mise à
l'honneur du régime en queue de défilé
le jour du 14 juillet pour eux nous
militaires ça compte beaucoup
se présenter devant notre chef le
président la république c'est un grand
honneur voilà et donc oui tout le monde
ici est très fière sachant que la
plupart des équipages qui sont présents
aujourd'hui était il y a peu de temps au
sel en train de se battre
contre les groupes armés terroristes en
appui des pays partenaires qu'on a dans
la région donc oui pour eux pour eux
c'est très important merci beaucoup
écouté non je vous en prie et josette
maintenant un excellent envol merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
le caractère prouvé qu'elle admire à
vendre
en dépit des deux fois et on les pros
[Musique]
dans cette voie là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
donc là il est 15h30 on vient tout juste
d'atterrir achats pour nous ça s'est
super bien passé on va demander au
pilote directement comment comment vous
vous êtes senti pendant pendant ces deux
heures de vol à peu près donc vers paris
écoutez ça s'est très bien passé je
pense qu'on était bien dans le timing au
passage champs elysées avec une belle
formation donc je pense c'est une
répétition qui est plutôt réussi c'est
des vols qu'on n'a pas du tout
l'habitude de faire parce que d'habitude
on vole plus tôt près du sol avec des
aéronefs qui suit pas les mêmes
trajectoires la particularité c'est
qu'il faut tenir la formation par
rapport aux hélicoptères qui sont devant
nous et également par rapport aux
hélicoptères qui sont à nos côtés donc
c'est c'est plutôt technique à faire
mais c'est assez sympa comment vous
faites pour arriver à la seconde près au
niveau de la tribune présidentielle le
jour j alors on a la chance d'avoir un
hélicoptère qui est assez modernes
équipés de gps et de beaucoup de
systèmes qui nous permette d'arriver à
la seconde près à sur l'objectif merci
beaucoup vous remercie
donc là on est avec le lieutenant
colonel armand et on va visiter
l'hélicoptère voir un peu comment ça
s'organise à l'intérieur donc à
l'intérieur comme vous le voyez il ya
une partie avant une partie arrière la
partie soute un peu comme dans un avion
la partie qui sert à transporter tout le
monde avec la particularité c'est que
dans la partie arrière tout à l'arrière
vous avez tous les équipements radio qui
sont déportés de l'avant et bien sûr à
l'avant nous avons le cockpit le poste
de pilotage là où tout se passe
alors dites nous un peu comment comment
ça s'organise là il ya plein de touche
partout quand comment vous faites pour
piloter un tel engin alors de façon
générale vous avez cette commande qu'ils
passent cycliques qui va influer en
profondeur et sur la gauche et sur la
droite
cette commande qui est le pas générale
qui va permettre de monter descendre qui
donne delà de la puissance ici vous avez
tous les paramètres moteur que ce soit
la pression les temps des températures
ici vous avez tous les paramètres de vol
donc les écrans sont éteints mais vous
avez tout ce qui est cap altimétrie
montée ou descente tout ce qui est
radionavigation
en bas vous avez tout ce qui est radar
pilote automatique et tout ce qui est
communication se retrouve complètement
en bas
ici vous avez toutes les radios qui nous
permet de communiquer en vol voilà pour
un particulier vous avez ici un petit
gps qui nous aident et là ce qu'on
appelle un pavé de voyants d'alarmé donc
c'est le ce sont les voyants qu'ils ne
doivent pas être allumées lorsque nous
sommes en vol ok merci beaucoup voilà il
est 16h tout s'est très bien passé les
équipages sont en train de terminer le
matériel les commandants de bord et les
pilotes eux sont au débriefing et si
tout s'est bien passé et bien rendez
vous le 14 juillet à l'arc de triomphe
voilà pour ce
mode et les mêmes qui étaient sur cette
base aérienne et jean recevoir nos deux
prochains invités qui vont commenter
avec moi ce défilé du 14 juillet d'abord
florent de saint victor auteur du blog
marsatac bonjour florent et commandant
guillaume officiers de l'armée de terre
en jour vous n'hésitez pas bien sûr tout
au long cela va continuer a commenté
pour voir enfin voilà n'hésitez pas à
poser vos questions nous on est là pour
rayer y répondre il ya des gens qui ne
savent pas forcément comment marche ce
défilé pourquoi est on est là pour vous
expliquer toutes ces choses là je
d'ailleurs dans les commentaires je vois
que vous êtes très nombreux déjà à nous
à nous poser vos atouts pas forcément
nous posent des questions mais surtout
pour nous dire bonne fête nationale on
nous irons nous regardent d'australie
d'elina la france est le plus beau pays
du monde
voilà c'est vrai que on le disait tout à
l'heure c'est un élément de soft power
ce 14 juillet c'est un élément les armes
et se se montre face à leur nation donc
à un moment particulier qui n'arrive pas
souvent souvent les défilent dans une
carrière militaire on peut défiler une
fois deux fois donc c'est vraiment un
moment particulier pour ceux qui ceux
qui défigurent à leurs familles les
enfants qui seront derrière les écrans
qui seront fiers de leur prépa de leur
maman de de la personne qui connaissent
donc c'est vraiment un moment
particulier où un temps donné aux armes
et aux autres forces à tous ceux qui
savent quelque chose qui les dépasse
quelque chose donc pour nous pour la
france donc vraiment un moment
particulier avant en particulier on va
rejoindre julien leclercq sur le terrain
la base aérienne de villacoublay ils se
trouvent actuellement sur cette base
militaire julien c'est à vous
savez
bonjour vincent effectivement je suis à
la base militaire 107 à vélizy
villacoublay dans les yvelines en ile de
france je suis avec le général emmanuel
josse bonjour général bonjour alors le
défilé du 14 juillet c'est une atteinte
extrêmement importante pour vos hommes
pour une femme est-ce que vous êtes
prêts alors oui bien sûr on est prêt
parce qu'on s'est entraîné les jours
derniers mais il faut avoir à l'esprit
que cet exercice qu'on va réaliser c'est
à dire le volant patrouille sur le vol à
plusieurs appareils
évoluant à proximité
c'est pas un exercice
habituel pour les gendarmes des forces
de gendarmerie
parce qu'en fait on est
dispersée sur tout le territoire
national sur 29 base opérationnelle et
la plupart débats sont à une une machine
un appareil donc en fait le fait se
retrouver à trois voire quatre appareils
comme ce matin c'est assez inhabituel
donc c'est parce que le principe des
forces aériennes de la gendarmerie c'est
vraiment un appareil sur un territoire
c'est le maillage territorial sur le
territoire national pour réaliser toutes
les missions de sécurité publique de la
gendarmerie et justement du coup ces
missions vous les commandez ces forces
là depuis deux ans depuis il me semble
le 15 juillet 2020
ces missions qu'elles sont elles alors
l'émission en fait c'est tout le large
spectre des missions de sécurité
publique de la gendarmerie c'est à dire
ça peut consister aussi bien des
recherches de malfaiteurs des
surveillances lors de grands
rassemblements de personnes et puis bien
sûr on porte assistance aux populations
dans certaines situations notamment en
montagne ou lors de grands évènements de
grande crise majeure n'oublions pas
aussi que nous sommes aussi là pour
réaliser des missions de
contreterrorisme le cas échéant ou
pourra intervenir aussi comme c'était le
cas l'été dernier sur des forcenés et si
je comprends bien vous avez une grande
expérience là dedans ce que je voulais
savoir parmi vos missions et je pense de
plus en plus le temps le soleil radieux
et la chaleur de cette journée nous le
rappelle c'est aussi l'assistance et
bien aux forces de sécurité notamment
dans la lutte contre les incendies c'est
une mission importante est ce que c'est
une mission vous êtes de plus en plus
sollicités pour intervenir alors oui on
est de plus en plus sollicités pour
intervenir sur les situations de crise
quelle qu'elle soit c'est à dire qu'en
effet la vous évoquez les incendies
parce que c'est c'est vraiment le sujet
de la saison mais en fait toute l'année
on est vraiment sollicité sur bien sûr
les événements majeurs de type
catastrophe naturelle mais aussi
les crises on va dire social économique
les troubles à l'ordre public sur
lesquels nous intervenons aussi donc
vous voyez bien que en fait c'est un
outil d'appui aérien d'appui 3d qui est
vraiment au service de la population au
plus près de la population
et qui est réalisé 365 jours par an et
joua pour répondre à votre question oui
l'engagement dé continuer à creuser
chaque année
et si j'ai bien compris vous êtes saint
cyrien vous avez pu défiler sur les
champs elysées à pied maintenant vous
défiler dans les airs c'est un prestige
particulier est ce que quelle est la
différence qu'il ya entre ces deux
situations
alors bien sûr il se trouve
qu'aujourd'hui jour pour jour il ya 30
ans précisément 30 ans c'est un chiffre
tout rond jeux défilaient sur les
champs-elysées à pied sous l'uniforme du
saint cyrien donc c'est un petit peu un
clin d'oeil voilà du parcours
professionnels que j'ai pu accomplir
donc c'est une petite fierté et une
certaine joie aujourd'hui de de faire
écho à mai mais pas lorsque j'avais 22
ans là maintenant voilà je vais être sûr
sur la troisième dimension à un autre
niveau et met ses c'est aussi le plaisir
de cet événement festif que reste le 14
juillet alors c'est ce que j'ai compris
c'est que effectivement il y a de la
préparation mais il ya aussi le plaisir
de démontrer tout le dispositif qui est
mise en place est ce que vous êtes fier
de ce que vos hommes ont accompli bien
sûr et je suis surtout fier de ce qu'ils
ont accompli depuis 70 ans puisque
l'année prochaine où nous fêterons les
70 ans d'efforts cn de la gendarmerie
donc depuis les pionniers de
l'aéronautique en hélicoptère en france
dans les années 50 jusqu'à aujourd'hui
on a une évolution assez extraordinaire
avec un engagement des presque 500
femmes et hommes que constituent les
forces de la gendarmerie et c'est une
vraie fierté de pouvoir les voir évoluer
et être tous les jours quotidiennement
engagé au service de la population et le
14 juillet aujourd'hui mais disons que
c'est le symbole qui porte ce ce doux le
sens qui est le 14 juillet un sens très
sérieux qui est le sens de l'engagement
et le sens du collectif puisque bien sûr
on est con on défile ensemble et il faut
une vraie coordination pour défiler
ensemble et finalement le 14 juillet
c'est aussi l'idée que un plus un ça
fait plus que deux
c'est le sens absolument sérieux très
sérieux du 14 juillet et puis le
deuxième sens et c'est le sens festif
tout simplement où on se retrouve tous
ensemble et citoyen pour fêter cette
fête nationale en général
écoutez vincent de notre côté on va pas
tarder à décoller ce dispositif dont
parlait le général emmanuel josse
justement va décoller va se mettre en
place on vous rejoins tout à l'heure au
dessus des champs je vous laisse la
place libre c'est à vous merci beaucoup
julien merci au général emmanuel josse
d'avoir été avec nous pour cette
interview on va retourner très
rapidement d'abord du côté des images
alors voilà on va retourner d'avoir
voilà donc avec timothée timothée qui se
trouve avec un officier timothée est ce
que vous m'entendez bien voilà est-ce
que vous avez est-ce que vous pouvez
nous
dire à vos ce qui se passe là bas
oui vincent on attend impatiemment le
début du défilé moi je suis avec le
commandant stéphane qui est qui est ici
pour ce pour assister à ce défilé vous
avez vous des filets il ya je crois 17
ans vous me disiez c'est toujours un
moment émouvant important pour un
militaire de défiler sur les
champs-elysées pour le 14 juillet
absolument c'est un grand moment pour le
militaire d'autant plus que c'est rare
comme on vous l'avait dit je n'étais
fils et qu'il ya 17 ans déjà et dont
c'est toujours un honneur de venir ici
alors ça demande du temps de préparation
ça demande beaucoup de rigueur dans la
préparation et mais surtout c'est une
opération de communication avec la
nation enfin de liens avec la nation on
partage la flamme alors cette année
c'est particulier donc c'est aussi un
excellent thème le partage de la flamme
notamment
avec les anciens avec notamment du
benjamin qui est décédé au mois
d'octobre et asnières le dernier
compagnon de la libération c'est le
partage la flamme aussi parce que les
jeux olympiques approchent donc il ya
une transmission de la flamme à travers
ses défilés et enfin le
voilà c'est tous ces éléments là
c'est toujours un grand moment pour nous
autres qui ment d'être présents et de
passer de traverser la ville de paris au
milieu des français va essayer de se
mettre dans la tête de ces six mille
trois cents militaires qui vont défiler
sur les champs-élysées d'ici quelques
minutes qu'est ce qui se passe au moment
de défiler comme ça devant devant cesser
ces dizaines de milliers de personnes
qui sont qui sont venus pour pourrait
bien pour regarder ce ces militaires des
filets
ben quand je vous le disais beaucoup
d'émotion on fait très attention ce que
nous avons
et pendant la répétition on fait
attention aux petits détails c'est un
exercice de rigueur voilà c'est
l'expression extrême du métier de
militaire je dirais presse pour tout ce
qui est
alors on dit que c'est un défilé doit
être carré comme comme vous et grandir
dans l'armée beaucoup de monde là on le
voit juste derrière nous cette troupe
qui si cette foule pardon qui est qui et
amassé on imagine que c'est émouvant
pour vous aussi de voir que ce lien
justement une île et les français et
l'armée en tout cas on voit que les
français sont toujours enclins à venir
assister à ce défilé oui absolument ils
sont c'est très émouvant de passer au
milieu d'eux de devaux engouement et de
voir leur soutien le soutien qu'ils nous
apportent toujours là et c'est important
pour nous de nous sentir aimée par la
nation parce que notre action notre
mission c'est bien de défendre les
intérêts de la nation et donc nous
sommes là pour défendre la patrie et
donc nous sommes fiers que cela
représente quelque chose pour certains
alors vous vous travaillez précisément
sur l'équipement individuel du
combattant dites nous un petit peu en
quoi cela consiste alors je suis à la
section technique de l'armée de terre
qui est un organisme unique dans
amateurs qui en fait expriment le besoin
d'évolution des équipements nous avons
par exemple le lay mix10 hershey qui
était un char qui est sorti en 78 et qui
va encore vivre quelques années avant
d'être remplacé par le jaguar est donc
en fait c'est ce char l'aï là il a subi
des évolutions depuis maintenant près de
50 ans et donc c'est nous qui
exprimeront le besoin d'évolution en
fonction du risque du retour
d'expérience en fonction des évolutions
technologiques et dans mon domaine des
équipements vidéo du combattant
nous avons nous faisons évoluer tous ces
équipements que ce soit le tri que ce
soit le gilet pare balles le casque et
je porte aujourd'hui le trim le futur
triomphe est de l'armée terre c'est un
nouveau tri qui va qui va sortir là
c'est ça oui il va sortir il va être
déployé en fait en france pour tout les
toutes les toutes les armes à partir de
2024 voilà c'est un truc qu'on a
développée sur lequel on a réfléchi
depuis 2016
ensuite on a on a fait des évaluations
vont la comparer tout un tas de tri on a
fait des évaluations de performance
technique et aujourd'hui c'est rien en
fait va remplacer à la fois le zone
centre europe le tri hiver vous pouvez
voir un petit peu partout vers centre
europe ainsi que le tri zone désertique
ce sont deux tri qui ont 30 ans
d'existence au début d'année fin aux
guerres du golfe pour le tri zone
désertique et début des années 90 pour
le centre europe et donc et il va
remplacer cette génération de camouflage
par usages multi environnement c'est à
dire qu'il est adapté à tous les
environnements indépendamment de la zone
désertique ou de la zone verte
voilà il est très performant et plus
performant que l'actuel merci beaucoup
commandant stéphane le commandant qui va
donc maintenant et bien comme nous
regarder ce défilé un défilé qui est
vraiment sur le point de commencer
puisque on me dit dans l'oreillette que
le président l'impliquent emmanuel
macron est en train d'arriver sur place
devant timothée le président est arrivé
sur place on va peut-être voir ces
images en direct tourné par la lfp voilà
nous avons emmanuel macron qui est sur
place qui va prendre place comme en
anglais parce que vous expliquer un peu
ce qui va se passer maintenant
pour ce défilé avec les manu mcqueen il
prend place il a fait une revue des
troupes ça exactement exactement le
président qui est le chef des armées va
maintenant effectuer la revue de
l'ensemble des troupes qui vont défiler
aujourd'hui devant les français et c'est
donc le premier moment important pour
ces troupes être passés en revue par le
président ce n'est pas quelque chose
d'anodin et je peux vous dire qu'ils
sont tous très fiers d'être passés en
revue et ensuite très concentré pour le
défilé qui les attend effectivement là
c'est vraiment le coup d'envoi on peut
dire que là ça y est c'est le coup
d'envoi du défilé c'est ce moment là
alors le coup d'envoi a démarré à 4
heures ce matin pour la plupart des
troupes 1 qui ont dû se lever se prépare
et rejoindre rejoindre pareil pour le
défier et là c'est le début du combat
c'est jose si j'ose dire mais le coup
d'envoi est parti il ya quelques heures
est ce que vous vous avez déjà défilé
soit janvier vous pouvez me dire un peu
comment ça se passe qui dit finalement
alors oui j'ai eu la chance de défiler
sur les champs-elysées comme le général
précédemment puisque je suis saint
cyrien et donc j'ai pu défiler lors de
ma dernière année à saint cyr lorsque
j'étais au 1er bataillon
c'est le seul défi des filets que j'ai
eu l'honneur de faire sur les champs
elysées je ne je ne désespère pas de
pouvoir en faire encore dans le reste de
ma carrière et donc aujourd'hui vont
défiler sur les champs tout d'abord une
une partie aérienne avec les avions
principalement de l'armée de l'air et de
l'espace celui ensuite du défilé des
troupes à pied qui est le défilé auquel
j'ai participé puisque les écoles un
participant au défilé au défilé à pied
suivie d'un défilé des hélicoptères des
armes et principalement ceux de
l'aviation légère de l'armée de terre
est terminée par un défilé motorisé avec
les différents équipements et véhicules
blindés que vous pourrez voir défiler
aujourd'hui et conclu par la garde
républicaine à cheval voilà pour le
programme vous n'hésitez pas à continuer
à commenter je vois que vous êtes
toujours très nombreux à commenter vous
n'hésitez pas à poser vos questions je
n'en vois pas beaucoup pour l'instant
mais surtout là vous n'hésitez pas on
est là pour y répondre même si vous ne
connaissez pas grand chose finalement à
ce défi du 14 juillet il ne faut pas
évident il ne faut pas hésiter du tout
florence 1 victoire vous vous disiez il
ya un coup d'envoi à ce défilé à coup
d'envoi qui est donnée par le président
voilà c'est dans une fois que le
président va terminer le passage de deux
des troupes en passage les troupes en
revue il va avoir les honneurs qui sont
rendus donc par la garde républicaine
avec la marseillaise puis après le
président va rejoindre la tribune
présidentielle et au moment où il
s'avéra
peu importe qu'ils soient des minutes ou
3 minutes en avance ou en retard par
rapport au programme prévu le moment
présidence à soi c'est le coût des coups
de départ pour l'alignement des avions
pour la mise en place du pas sur les
unités à terre pour le démarrage des
véhicules c'est vraiment voilà quand le
président ça soit c'est là où on sera
six un peu en avance un peu en retard se
font assez exacte mais voilà c'est le
top départ pour cette opération qui est
un peu le défilé comme finalement entre
agences et des véhicules des avions des
personnes qui marchent à différents
rythmes c'est une sacrée opération de
deux fermes nsa de mener ça vient donc
voilà avec des cadencements très précis
c'est comme un game on imagine que en
termes de timing il ait à synchroniser
tout ça c'est quand même et dans la
préparation oui c'est une opération
militaire complète classique d'ailleurs
vous avez pour la partie aérienne un
centre de commandement aérien en haut de
l'arc de triomphe qui est là pour
coordonner l'ensemble du défilé aérien
et ensuite pour les troupes à pied pour
les troupes en véhicule tout le monde
est en liaison radio et finalement à
préparer ce défilé comme une opération
militaire mais pour une fois une
opération militaire que l'on a plaisir à
réaliser on voit le président de
république est en train de descendre sur
les champs-elysées avec les troupes qui
vont défiler et c'est ça le fun de
passage en revue des troupes est
exactement le passage en revue des
troupes c'est le passage de l'autorité
devant l'ensemble des troupes et
l'autorité prend toujours une attention
particulière regardez les troupes dans
les yeux c'est celle usage au sein des
armées de manière une manière au chef de
montrer qu'ils portent attention à ses
subordonnés puisque le passage en revue
des troupes date d'époque plus anciennes
où le chef passé en revue ses soldats
avant de partir à la bataille est donc
les échanges de regards permettait de
faire passer une compréhension et une
estime mutuelle une petite question
histoire pour l'un de vous deux amauri
qui le demande quand est ce qu a été
institué le défilé du 14 juillet alors
le défilé du 14 juillet a été instituée
jeu je n'ai pas la réponse exacte mais
pour moi la fin du 19e siècle il n'a pas
toujours été sur les champs elysées il a
été au tout début tournant et sur les
champs dans les grands boulevards à
vincennes ou à d'autres endroits il est
arrivé véritablement sur les
champs-elysées après la deuxième guerre
mondiale où on a décidé de l'institut
est ici au centre au coeur de paris sur
la plus belle avenue effectivement
benoît qui nous dit pourrait-on dire un
mot sur le chef d'état major le général
buhler garde est ce qu'on peut déjà dire
qui est le qu'est ce que c'est le chef
d'état-major contre hector
ce qui était intéressant de voir à la le
camp le le président de la république
est monté à bord du commandant commandes
cas avec le président il ya eu des
échanges de mots qu'on n'entend jamais
voilà deux entre deux autorités
le chef des armées l'autorité politique
et le commandant on va dire suprême des
forces militaires dont le général burqa
donc des échanges de balles à des
échanges de entre deux chefs entre deux
personnes qui ont qui se voient
régulièrement donc le général burqa
renom qui est le chef d'état-major des
armées l'ancien chef d'état major de
l'armée de terre y encore quelques
années donc qui est le niveau de haut
est l'autorité suprême des armées le
niveau de coordination au dessus le m à
qui l'état major des armées qui est au
dessus des différentes armées air terre
mer qu'on connaît peut-être plus
traditionnellement donc voilà c'est de
l'autorité militaire
suprême donc avec dans la constitution
tout un rôle
celui de conseiller de celui de
conseiller du gouvernement celui qui a
autorité celui qui propose des plans
celui qui décide sulky mais qui met en
oeuvre donc une personne centrale dans
la défense la défense française c'est en
effet lui qui est en charge de
l'ensemble des opérations des armées
françaises donc vous savez que chaque
armée à son propre chef d'état major
mais même si l'armée de terre est engagé
en opération par exemple au sahel
actuellement c'est le chef d'état-major
des armées avec son état-major son état
major et le centre particulier de
commandement des opérations qui lui est
responsable 24 heures sur 24 devant la
france et le président du déroulé des
opérations françaises alors on à anosy
kaki j'adore cette fête nationale du 14
juillet pour moi ça représente surtout
toutes les années où je regardais avec
mon père on le disait tout à l'heure
c'est un soft power à la française ce 14
juillet ça représente quand même quelque
chose
c'est une institution avec ce drapeau
bleu blanc rouge qui est muet sur l'arc
de triomphe pour l'événement il ya un
acte de crédibilité aussi deux de ses
pas uniquement montrer sa force mais il
ya aussi un peu quelque chose comme ça
donc voilà une unité vous en parliez
tout à l'heure avec nicolas barotte qui
disait que voilà l'unité de la nation
et une force en soi pour la défense la
défense de la nation donc voilà c'est la
communion de la nation de ses armées et
puis une démonstration aussi des
capacités aériennes terrestres et
navales des armées qui sont mises au
grand jour donc il ya aussi un message
qui a envoyé voilà d'une d'une nation
soudée d'une nation voilà qui partagent
cet élan cette flamme
autour autour d'eux des gardiens de ces
murailles oui tout à fait et d'ailleurs
c'est je reprends le les mots de
communion puisque les militaires qui
défilent aujourd'hui devant la france
sont profondément fier de montrer qu'ils
sont ici pour servir la france
profondément fier mais cette communion
est aussi réalisée par la simple
présence des citoyens au bord des champs
ou derrière leur télé ou les militaires
le ressentent comme une acceptation une
reconnaissance de leur travail de leur
de leurs fonctions au service de la
france et je peux vous dire que c'est un
grand grand sentiment de fierté et c'est
ça que vous avez ressenti vous quand
vous aviez défilé vous voyez tous ces
gens alors les deux dernières années ont
été plus compliquées nous à cause du
contexte sanitaire mais là il y aura du
monde le long des champs c'est celle que
vous ressentez c'est une vraie fierté
oui tout à fait une vraie fierté et est
presque si j'ose dire une sorte
d'euphorie puisqu'il y à vraiment il ya
vraiment un sentiment un sentiment
physique un sentiment physique de
reconnaissance par la nation et c'est
quelque chose auquel les militaires
présents sont très sensibles alors je
salue christian léon toussaint qui vient
de nous rejoindre alors que le président
lui continue à descendre sur les champs
elysées ça prend à peu près combien de
temps ça prend à un gros quart d'heure
ils passent ils payent ils défilent aux
idées sans les l'avenue et au pas des
chevaux donc ait certains et puis voilà
comme le disait le commandant voilà il
ya un échange de regards dans les andes
entre les troupes les emblèmes et les
étendards de chacune des unités qui
s'abaisse au passage du chef les garde à
vous qui sont faits pour autant de deux
symboles forts qui ont du sens pour les
militaires que des quelque chose qui est
profondément ancrée pour eux de de
respect et puis la posture du chef des
armées droite a cherché ce regard à
chercher cette confiance a montré cette
confiance j'ai confiance en vous il ait
confiance en moi donc cet échange mutuel
entre entre les deux voilà qui qui donne
cet élan encore une fois la garde
républicaine qui accompagnent
chef d'état est que c'est
les hommes qui en fou qui aucun parti
est-ce qu'ils agissent redire à
l'extérieur aussi ou est ce qui reste
ils sont affectés à ces derniers le
week-end alors là la garde républicaine
est une unité de gendarmerie c'est une
unité de gendarmerie dont la vocation
principale est la protection des
emprises institutionnels et des grands
personnages de l'état français et donc
protection de la présidence de l'elysée
du parlement et donc ce sont des gens
dont c'est le métier c'est le métier ils
ne font pas que des filets ils sont ils
sont formés pour défendre le président
en forme et pour défendre les
institutions et donc aujourd'hui bien
évidemment on les voit sur leurs chevaux
avec leurs sabres mais ils manipulent
plus souvent une véritable arme que
qu'un sabre de d'apparat d'ailleurs une
petite anecdote sur la garde à cheval
qui défilent donc qui accompagnent le
président dans sa revue des troupes vous
comprenez qu'ils sont les premiers à
descendre les champs elysées et donc
malheureusement les chevaux n'ont pas la
capacité à se retenir de laisser
quelques déjections derrière eux et je
peux vous dire que pour toutes les
troupes qui défile à pied il ya une
concentration particulière pour se dire
que eh bien si jamais j'arrive face à ce
que l'on peut appeler une mine il faut
que je reste concentré et surtout
surtout ne pas glisser et effectivement
est-ce qu'on a droit de dévier le pas
pour éviter du coup et bien non non non
il faut marcher droit un droit dessus
être concentré et puis et puis vous
voyez toutes les années ça se passe très
bien oui et alors il faut aussi arriver
à gérer ses chevaux parce qu'on imagine
que ils ont l'habitude mais il peut
aussi avoir quelques petits ratés
peut-être pas mal lors des précédentes
années tout toujours il ya malgré le
talent comme le régiment de la cavalerie
lagardère et la partie cavalerie de la
garde républicaine sont quand même des
cavaliers émérites avec un haut niveau
en équitation et chaque année avec le
bruit et autres lits peut avoir quelques
fois où le sabot qui glisse sur le pavé
le pavé rarement très apprécié des
chevaux il ya quelques quelques écarts
mais voilà aujourd'hui
on voit aux images tout se passe bien
voilà ils sont habitués dès leur plus
jeune âge aux bruits de la fanfare qu'on
entend derrière voilà c'est comme le
disait le commandant au delà de la
représentation comme c'est aussi le
symbole à la française connue là on est
dans la bien avec public n c'est une
pure siav soft power on se souvient d'un
cheval de la garde républicaine est
offert pour le pour l'anniversaire de la
reine comme symbole voilà deux un cadeau
bien à la française à la ceni du
software mais aussi voilà il ya toute la
partie plus militaire plus d'opérations
avec même des éléments de la garde
républicaine qui un peu comme qui vont
en soutien de la gendarmerie dans les
départements outre-mer à tour de rôle
aussi il ya des pelotons d'intervention
la de la garde qui partent dans les
outre-mer donc voilà ils font pas juste
la parade très bien défiler comme ils
savent très bien défiler on verra si
c'est des alignements ultra correct
comme c'est ça fait une grande partie de
leurs leur leur mission mais il ya aussi
voilà des forces des emprises avec des
spécificités très importante par exemple
peut parler à la lutte de la lutte anti
drones qui est très développée non j'ai
la garde républicaine comme c'est un
sujet une menace particulière sur les
emprises sur les autres personnalités
donc ce ne sont pas juste des baux
uniforme qui défilent derrière il ya il
ya des vraies missions menées au
quotidien par la garde alors vous voyez
manuel macro qui est en train d'arriver
devant la tribune officielle avec la
garde républicaine ils sont en chemin il
ya un enjeu de sécurité comment
guillaume pendant ce défilé il faut
garantir la sécurité du président
pendant tout ce défilé et pendant qu'ils
passent et on nous fait on imagine et on
l'a entendu avec deux journalistes il ya
des beaucoup de commandes et des
précautions qui sont prises oui
exactement alors il y à la sécurité du
président a assuré mais il ya la
sécurité des troupes et surtout de
l'ensemble des citoyens qui participent
qui participent aux 14 ou 15 ans juillet
est donc en effet il y a un
très grand nombre de cordon de sécurité
de zone d'interdiction tout autour de la
zone de défiler pour empêcher une
éventuelle agression par le sol mais
vous avez aussi un très gros dispositif
de défense aérienne ainsi mises en place
au dessus de paris donc de défense
aérienne complet qui serait capable de
s'opposer à des avions ou à des missiles
mais surtout dernièrement à des drones
et dont vous avez toujours depuis ce
centre de commandement en haut de l'arc
de triomphe des équipes de lutte anti
drones avec des antennes un des moyens
radars et des moyens électromagnétiques
répartis sur l'ensemble de la capitale
qui sont en mesure de neutraliser
d'empêcher d'agir un éventuel le drone
c'est à dire que le drone siens donne
qui arrivent ils prennent le contrôle
ils le font tomber ou alors ils ont
différentes différentes capacités ils
peuvent soit le stopper sur la zone dans
laquelle il est en train d'évoluer soit
le faire tomber soit leur envoyer un le
renvoyer vers versons vers celui qui est
en train de le télécommande et si jamais
ils ont à le faire tomber il s'arrange
pour le faire un endroit où il n'y
aurait personne personne dessous puisque
ce serait dommageable et si le renvoi
vers l'opérateur et bien ils ont un
moyen de suivi pour arriver à retrouver
l'opérateur qui aurait envoyé son droit
dans un interdite
alors on va aller sur place on va les
revoir timothée timothée d'hellemmes qui
a suivi le passage des manuels mâcon
est-ce que timothée vous pouvez nous
dire comment ça s'est passé si le
président a été applaudi à son passage
alors on va reprendre tout à l'heure tu
veux tu j'avais une question dans le
dans le chat des vannes du duo qui nous
le monde est ce que la guerre en ukraine
va influencer ce 14 juillet
alors écoutez
la réponse courte ce sera oui puisque
vous le verrez en tête du défilé à pied
vous allez voir défiler neuf nations du
flanc est de l'europe et de l'otan et
donc ses neuf stations sont bien
évidemment mises en avant dans cette
période troublée un période troublée à
laquelle a réagi réagi l'otan et
notamment en mettant en place des
missions de réassurance ce que l'on
appelle des missions de rassurant c'est
à dire déployer des troupes dans ces
pays de l'otan qui sont sur le flanc
ouest flanc flanc instable actuellement
et donc un déploiement de troupes qui
vise à dissuader d'éventuelles actions
qui pourraient être portées contre des
pays membres de l'union européenne ou de
l'autre et puis quelque chose qui alors
si la guerre en ukraine influence il ya
une autre actualité qui a influencé
directement ce défilé c'est certains
appareils qui vont pas défilé qu'ils
sont sur place actuellement en gironde
pour lutter contre les incendies ça t'a
fait voilà le con appelle le box donc
chaque dans le défilé aérien il ya
plusieurs box dont plusieurs ski
plusieurs ensemble d'appareils qu'ils
sont représentatifs d'une fonction et
autres et donc le box de la sécurité
civile avec les trop fameux hélas
canadair les biches kraft et autres
appareils de lutte anti incendie il ya
toujours un point d'interrogation
parce que le défilé malgré son
importance quand le le plein quand il ya
péril dans sa demeure on envoie les les
moyens qu'il faut donc du côté de
bordeaux où un terrible incendie en
train de se propager donc voilà donc
canadair et autres ont plus forte à
faire voilà et on pourra parler
lorsqu'on lorsqu'ils passeront y aura
aussi les unités de la sécurité civile
ou des unités militaires du génie qui
viennent en soutien de tous ces pompiers
qui luttent
depuis quelques jours déjà maintenant
face à ces incendies alors on voit sur
ces images et emmanuel macron avec deux
militaires à côté de lui le général
burkhard et une autre personne est ce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer qui sait
si vous le reconnaissez
c'est le gouverneur militaire de paris
le général ahmad
manawi donc le gouverneur militaire de
paris qui est en fait en charge de
l'ensemble des missions de défense dans
la région parisienne donc sur paris mais
aussi dans la région ile de france dans
son ensemble et donc le gouverneur
militaire de paris est principalement
connu pour être le responsable du défilé
du 14 juillet mais ce n'est en fait même
si c'est une mission qu'il occupe à
temps plein toute l'année ce n'était en
fait que l'une des nombreuses missions
qu'il a à réaliser en région parisienne
avec notamment par exemple la
coordination de l'opération sentinel un
qui a lieu depuis maintenant 2015 dans
la région mais aussi toutes les autres
opérations qui pourraient appliquer de
près ou de loin des forces aux normes
est l'envoyé mamadou qui salue quatre
personnes militaires est ce que vous
pouvez tous tirent aussi du qu'il s'agit
oui donc là vous voyez le président qui
salue un les trois chefs d'état major
des armées et le directeur général de la
gendarmerie nationale donc le chef
d'état major de l'armée de terre que
vous pouvez reconnaître car il est dans
la la même couleur que moi c'est jose si
j'ose dire le général le général schyle
et puis ensuite vous avez le chef d'état
major de l'armée de l'air qui est le
général rollet et puis le chef
d'état-major de la marine l'amiral
vandier et enfin le directeur général de
la gendarmerie nationale le général
rodriguez très bien alors on a une
question d'amour itou demande comment
sont sélectionnés les troupes qui
défilent est ce que ce sont les mêmes
chaque année
non ce ne sont pas les mêmes chaque
année il ya alors il ya non et oui
voilà chaque année par exemple
les écoles voilà bien la promo de la
promotion de la dernière année souvent
du temps de formation va défiler donc la
gagne et on les retrouve donc tous les
élèves de saint cyr défi normalement une
fois tout à fait sauf pas de chance
comme une quelques déçus quelques fois
pour donner à voir des raisons médicales
ou autres donc il ya une certaine unité
une constance avec certaines unités qui
défilent tous les ans et puis
d'autrefois est en fait s'il ya le thème
donc pas typiquement aujourd'hui donc
l'actualité craignait le commandant qui
qui qui fait qu'ils orientent ça il ya
aussi souvent la mise en avant des
unités qui reviennent d'opérations donc
avant-hier l'afghanistan aujourd'hui le
sel et le la roumanie où certaines
unités qu'on verra et était il ya encore
quelques temps et voilà il ya une sorte
de turn over avec des messages qui sont
envoyées à chaque fois donc voilà à
chaque fois c'est en tout cas c'est un
grand honneur c'est souvent d une
décision qui a prises plusieurs mois al
avance avec un moment une beaucoup de
répétitions au quartier dans les
casernes et dans les unités pendant de
longs mois puis après tout le monde se
rassemble à satory notamment pour la
partie à pied et
pour aligner pour tout bien répéter pour
tout finaliser mais voilà c'est cela
aussi un temps long de plusieurs mois
pour arriver le jour j impeccablement
alors on va retrouver timothée
d'hellemmes timothée d'hellemmes qui se
trouve toujours sous et champs elysées
timothée vous avez suivi le passage des
manuels macro est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire comment il a été reçu
alors vous arrivait justement un moment
où la foule la semaine se mettent à
applaudir des applaudissements que l'on
n'a pas entendu lorsque emmanuel macron
est passé il est passé vraiment il ya
quelques minutes la avec le chef d'état
major des armées le général tim burke
thierry burkhard pardon ils sont passés
donc sur le sur le command car le
command car ils sont passés juste devant
nous dans un dans un calme étonnant pas
de passif l'aimé pas non plus de grands
de grands applaudissements le chef de
l'état qui a salué la foule d'un geste
de la main mais dans un dans un calme
dans un calme assez assez étonnant assez
saisissant et il est arrivé donc il a
descendu tous les champs elysées pour
arriver au niveau de la place de la
concorde là où vous l'avez vu sur sur
les images que vous diffusez depuis deux
buts à l'heure aucun vrai calme lorsque
lorsque le chef de l'état est passé
juste devant nous à quelques mètres et
le défilé à proprement parler qui se
prépare maintenant vous le voyez
peut-être derrière moi ce sont les
pionniers de la légion étrangère
ce sont eux qui vont ouvrir le défilé
traditionnellement ce sont que vous les
fêlés pourquoi et bien parce que ceux
qui sont en première ligne sur le sur le
sur le terrain lorsqu'ils sont bien
évidemment en opex dont quelques années
la légion étrangère et qui vont ouvrir
ce défilé ils sont juste juste derrière
moi au niveau de la place clemenceau et
il s'apprête à adé a démarré ce défilé
d'ici quelques quelques quelques
quelques secondes
c'est timothée on reviendra vers vous
alors que emmanuel macron et est en
train de passer alors je n'ai plus
l'image d'emmanuel mâcon est ce qu'on
peut
qu'est ce qu'on a vu sur ces images il
est passé de l'oqai les honneurs
militaires qui ont été rendus par un
détachement de la garde républicaine
un régiment d'infanterie donc tout à
leur envoyer à cheval le régiment de
cavalerie de la garde républicaine la c1
des détachements des deux régiments
d'infanterie de la garde républicaine
qui ont rendu les honneurs militaires
dont moment le l'étendard était et est à
la verticale du sol bc c'était au moment
de la marseillaise donc une la
marseillaise qui ouvre ses honneurs
militaires puis après le président a
passé en revue a terminé donc ce passage
en revue de comme il l'avait fait tout à
l'heure hélas le le chef du détachement
de la garde républicaine souvent lui
explique qui quels sont les troupes qui
lui ont rendu les honneurs voilà il n'y
a là aussi un petit mot allah on voit un
p'tit sourire un p'tit mot qui est
échangé entre le président et ce chef
alors oui nous pouvons une petite ligne
bleue qui est sur les champs elysées
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire à quoi
ça sert de ligne vous a fait c'est une
très importante d'ailleurs vous verrez
il y en a plusieurs elles servent à
aligner les troupes ou pas ligne et les
véhicules qui vont défiler de manière à
pouvoir tous restés parfaitement dans
laxe puisque puisque c'est un défilé de
plusieurs kilomètres un défilé de
plusieurs kilomètres où on est obligé de
regarder droit un droit devant soi et
donc on ne peut pas regarder sur les
côtés voir si l'on se trouve au bon
endroit et donc cette ligne bleue nous
permet du coin de l'oeil de vérifier que
l'on est parfaitement alignés dans notre
dispositif que tout va bien s'assurer
que ça va être pas mal de pression quand
des vies comme ça ne peux vous donner la
tête c'est cesser de la pression mais
finalement c'est de l'entraînement
puisque toutes les troupes qui qui défie
le ici se sont entraînés pendant
plusieurs jours chez elle se sont
entraînés pendant plusieurs jours en
région parisienne dans la région de
satory depuis depuis la semaine dernière
et comme je les dis ils ont préparé ce
défilé comme une opération militaire
donc ils seront parfaitement alignés
aujourd'hui donc emmanuel macron est en
train de prendre place actuellement on
gérard larcher président du sénat
elisabeth bornes la première dame il ya
les points d'arrivée président de
l'assemblée nationale qui est sur place
le prix dans la soirée et ça mettra à ça
donnera le coup d'envoi une nouvelle
voie mais ce ssd mais mais mais c'est
assez facile et les troupes commenceront
à pouvoir dire un peu qu'ils sont c'est
qu'ils sont ses troupes on a une
question de marc grinçant qui nous dit
pourrons nous voir des missiles qui
défilent comme par exemple en russie ou
en corée du nord eh bien vous verrez pas
difficile qui défilent en france alors
pour plusieurs raisons la première c'est
que la france ne fait pas défiler des
armes opérationnel sur son défilé du 14
juillet le message serait bien trop
agressif 1 et ensuite les missiles que
l'on peut voir défiler dans certaines
nations sont des missiles ou terrestre
or la france ne manie pas de missile
terrestre depuis depuis la fin de la de
la guerre froide et les seuls missiles
qui sont utilisés par la france sont des
missiles maritime ou aérien et donc dans
ce cas là vous ne pourriez pas les voir
défiler sur les champs comme la langue
il arrive qu'on parle business et des
missiles envoyés depuis la terre
exactement le plus la terre depuis des
véhicules véhicules à roues à chauny
très bien alors et on a une vision de
terry aussi alors sans rentrer dans les
détails du dispositif de sécurité qui ne
m'aurait ce qui est des snipers du raid
qui sont déployés sur les toits eh bien
écoutez je ne sais pas s'il ya des
snipers du raid ce que je sais c'est
qu'il y à des snipers de différentes
unités au moins des armées de la
gendarmerie met donc j'imagine très
probablement delà de la police nationale
puisque la préfecture de police de paris
et est aussi en charge de la sécurité
sur le champ donc je ne serais pas
surpris qu'il soit déployée sur
différents taux
alors que c'est l'animation de clôture
on veut on verra durant tous défilé il
ya plusieurs anniversaires à
d'importance qui sont fêtés durant ce
défilé est donc là il ya un anniversaire
tout particulier donc les 70 ans du
bagad de lann-bihoué donc un ensemble
musical de la marine nationale de la
bretagne un ensemble là aussi on est
dans du soft power on les a vus
régulièrement à l'étranger le bagad donc
au delà de défendre la bretagne est
aussi un symbole de la france plus
particulier qui sait des places se
déplace dans différents pays et
participe culturellement voilà à la
défense de ceux de cette france donc
c'est leurs 70 ans dont qui vont avoir
un petit en ensemble de différentes
musiques pour fêter cet anniversaire
on pourrait vous trouvez ça sans doute
désuet peut-être que ces fanfares
militaires qui remonte en fait à des
temps plus anciens où il fallait avoir
le courage de monter au front et donc
voilà stimuler tout le monde voilà et
autres ses souvenirs de voilà deux
cérémonies qui sont sans rien de 18,2
voilà de de rendre rendre de passer en
troupe s'est revus pour un chef d'avoir
cet échange de confiance c'est tout un
symbolique qui n'est pas juste
folklorique et donc voilà le bagad comme
d'autres musiques derrière je crois que
la musique de la flotte donc la musique
qui s'occupe qui est rattachée à
l'ensemble des unités flottantes de la
marine nationale on va les écouter juste
après quoi l'on va laisser passer
maintenant mais parce qu'ils ont dans la
musique
[Musique]
saleh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
pas
[Musique]
tous
voilà qu'est ce que vous est ce qu'on
peut dire ce qu'on a vu la haute en
terme de musique alors ces voix là c'est
un ensemble qui a été créé pour cette
animation d'ouverture donc plutôt joyeux
c'est pas forcément de la musique
militaire
classique ça monte d'ailleurs un peu le
panel de compétences de ses marins donc
et puis là pour l'effet visuel c'est
intéressant de voir des marins en blanc
à paris c'est plutôt rare souvent ils
sont tenus en tenue bleu plus foncé
parce que voilà il ya des codes ya tout
un règlement dans l'armée en beaucoup de
choses sont réglementées dont notamment
le la couleur des uniformes et c'est
rare de voir des marins laurent blanc le
deuxième ensemble au nord de la loire
c'est plutôt une tenue qui réservait
pour le sud est et les outre-mer et
voilà pour l'effet visuel à la fois les
le pompon le bachy le col du bagad en
bas et là aussi du blanc pour essayer de
faire sans doute des tons un peu
différente ah c'est plutôt rare voix
voilà c'est marrant blanc si on est est
ce que ces musiciens qui joue de la
cornemuse donc ça demande des
compétences de musique qu est ce qu ils
sont aussi militaire alors tu tapes et
sont sous contrat avec avec les armes et
donc là avec la marine nationale
des contrats non qui sont pas forcément
de carrière dont les contrats de trois
quatre cinq ans et autres c'est souvent
une bonne école de formation pour des
musiciens qui
généralement quand même un gros taux de
turnover donc ils vont danser ensemble
et après qui s'en vont vers d'autres
horizons mais c'est une école de
formation de rigueur aussi qui est
intéressant dans une carrière musicale
et donc ce sont des militaires voilà qui
on les verra pas forcément tous en
opération sur les théâtres extérieurs
on en parlera tout à l'heure peut-être
pour la musique de la légion étrangère
ou là ce sont des prévenus et des
militaires couplet on va dire qu'il
rencontre retrouve deux sur l'émission
sentinelle qui on retrouve sur des
renforts pour deux pour leurs camarades
qui défie les autres voilà mais oui ils
sont sous contrat
et c'est habituel que le 14 août
commence par de la musique comme ça ou
c'est pas pour les soixante dix ans de
douce et pour cet anniversaire alors
pour cet anniversaire en particulier
bien évidemment les 70 ans du bagad font
qu'il est mis à l'honneur à l'ouverture
du défilé maintenant
traditionnellement il ya toujours des
des activités d'ouverture du défilé qui
permettent alors de divertir un petit
peu la foule est aussi également de
gagner ou de raccourcir certains n'est
que l'on aurait pu prendre de manière à
pouvoir remettre remettre sur les rails
le défilé aérien le défilé à pied
puisque c'est toute une machinerie qui
pourraient se dérégler c'est à dire que
par exemple si le président est arrivé
que cinq minutes de retard le bagad veut
jouer 5000 de moins de musique pour que
le défilé commence à l'avant alors oui
c'est possible en fait ce sera fait en
coordination avec comme c'est le défilé
aérien qui ouvre le tube ouvre le bal
avec le centre de commandement qu'ils
soient
calculera hockey le bagad il leur reste
4 minutes et donc l'ensemble des voilure
fixe aériennes se prépare à décaler tous
leurs points de passage de quatre
minutes par exemple et simon et on va
voir ce ce défilé qui devrait commencer
un de danse passion à coeur est prévue
la patrouille de france paf et bien
écoutez la patrouille de france était
prévu à 10h34 donc nous sommes
actuellement légèrement en retard mais
donc ils ont dû recalés l'ensemble de
leurs de leurs points d'ailleurs vous
verrez la patrouille de france passée
sous le format qu'ils appellent le big
blind c'est à dire les neuf avions de la
patrouille qui ne défilent dans ce
format que pour le 14 juillet et que sur
les champs elysées pourquoi parce qu'en
fait la patrouille de france est
composée de neuf pilotes mais il n'y en
a toujours que 8 qui a huit qui
réalisent leurs différentes
démonstrations le neuvième étant le plus
expérimenté et donc garder en réserve en
cas où il y ait besoin de remplacer l'un
de ses l'un de ses camarades et le 14
juillet est le seul moment où l'on
engage si j'ose dire la réserve et que
donc l'ensemble des pilotes des films
vous voyez sur les images et le 70 qui
étaient étaient réalisés là cette heure
0 là vous les voyez leur alignement
la fête
le pilote en réserve comme en fait c'est
le plus expérimenté comme il doit être
capable de tenir tous les rôles donc en
fait il doit être capable de tenir les
huit autres rôles en réserve donc il
doit connaître la musique et les
enchaînements voilà si on sur le bout
des doigts et et autres des différentes
donc c'est vraiment celui qui a le plus
de bouteille
qui donc voilà tient ce rôle de
réserviste de luxe pour la patrouille de
france on a patrouillé on va au lustre
vous montrer alors partir un tout petit
peu des champs elysées pour retourner à
la base aérienne de villacoublay pour
voir un peu alors julien qui est dans
l'hélicoptère et qu'il va décoller d'ici
quelques instants qui a peut-être déjà
décollé on le voit ces post et d'image
mais en tout cas tout à l'air de se
mettre en place ils sont prêts à
décoller le voyage avec le son pantalon
puisque comme com
[Musique]
on n'entendra pas grand chose à tout cas
puisque il faut le dire dans ces
appareils il ya quand même beaucoup de
bruit on a du mal à s'entendre il y a
énormément de bruit que ce soit dans les
hélicoptères ou dans les avions tactique
et de combat des armes est d'ailleurs si
si vous prêtez attention vous verrez que
les soldats lorsqu'il monte dans un
avion tactique ou dans un hélicoptère
mettre leur protection auriculaire tout
comme lorsqu'ils le sont au tir parce
que le bruit est très fort et si l'on
reste plusieurs heures voire dizaines
d'heures dans dans la soute et bien on
peut finir par avoir des problèmes
décollez pas et qui va bientôt
survoler des champs elysées on verra si
on arrive alors la liaison avec julien
qui est sur place et qui pourra nous
faire ces images qu'on sait tous à quel
point qu'elles seront très belle on peut
peut-être retourner maintenant du côté
des
des champs elysées avec des
musiciens qui sont eux qui sont toujours
sur place n'est encore un petit peu avec
l'hélicoptère et les hélicos qu'à aller
se positionner au
dessus de au dessus de la région
parisienne ils vont former ce qu'on
appelle des hippodromes d'attentes donc
c'est à dire que vont faire des cercles
en attendant des grands cercles à
différents étages différents selon les
différentes vitesses comme fatih ce qui
est compliqué c'est à la fois pour les
avions est à la fois pour les
hélicoptères qui ont été des vitesses
qui sont très différentes donc ils vont
s'étager faire ces hippodromes d'attenté
au tome final ils vont petit à petit
quitter ces cercles d'attentes et
commencer l'alignement la défense le
champ l'arc de triomphe la tribune
présidentielle
voilà donc et en fait c'est là dessus ou
un sur les délais on peut on peut jouer
voilà c'est de l'ordre les hippodromes
d'attentes on commence à voir la
patrouille de france la patrouille de
france on arrive on va vous laisser
vivre ces images
la patrouille de france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
retour
que
à
[Musique]
il
là
carrier
en service dans l'armée de l'air pour le
ravitaillement civile de rafale
vous avez ensuite derrière que l'on peut
que l'on peut voir là le blog de soutien
vos ressortissants donc la mission a pas
grand qui s'est déroulé en afghanistan
l'année dernière avec toujours un a330
et un à 400m atlas l'avion vous voyez
avec quatre hélices a donc qui est un
avion tactique donc de transport
tactique en opération au plus près du
sol mais aussi sur de grandes de grandes
distances et ce et calyon c'est un poète
à évacuer les ressortissants français
c'était une grande opération donc l'été
dernier on s'en souvient peut-être en
août l'année dernière la situation s'est
dégradée en afghanistan il a fallu à les
évacuer en urgence c'est aussi ça la
l'arrivée réactivité des armes et
d'aller chercher en urgence des
ressortissants avec des points aérien
entre l'afghanistan et les émirats puis
les émirats et la france voilà c'est
très intéressant parce que vous avez le
bloc opérations extérieures donc avec un
ravitailleurs c135 et donc l'autre type
de ravitailleurs 2
de l'armée de l'air française suivi deux
mirage 2000 voilà vous les voyez donc
les quatre mirage 2000 formation en
losange derrière et sur les ailes à
l'arrière des rafale de l'armée de l'air
et de l'espace dans des images en même
temps devenir leclerc qui est en train
de passer
car dans ce monde une tension qui au
terme d'un train ils sont en train de
passer ces images de julien le cap on va
on va revenir peut-être plus tôt sur ce
qui se passe du côté du défilé avec à
nouveau ravitailleur c'est à dire que
les ravitailleurs leurs actes immondes
et des
ralliements se fait en vol tout à fait
il ya des on les voit peut-être sur les
images alors pas sur cet appareil sur
les précédents il y avait peut-être les
paniers qui était sorti donc au bout de
fil il ya des grosses panier où il
s'agit de de faire rentrer 1,1 une
perche de ravitaillement donc un petit
rhume donc c'est une manoeuvre vous
imaginez fait à plusieurs kilomètres
heure en l'air avec les turbulences où
le manoeuvre d'un sport de masse comme
iter vente à partir de là la connexion
entre le ravitailleur est ravitaillé il
ya un échange de carburant de plusieurs
tonnes de ravitaillement de
ravitaillement qui s'échangent et qui
permettent de faire durer plus longtemps
les vols où la limite est souvent la
limite physique des pilotes comme c'est
des vols qui peuvent être très éprouvant
alors là nous sommes en direct des
images de julien avec des hélicoptères
de la gendarmerie qui vont être en pole
en vol stationnaire et sur les images du
direct on voit quelque chose qui est
assez spécial un avion avec une coupole
qui tourne au dessus de lui oui donc là
vous voyez le bloc de la protection de
l'espace aérien avec en tête le fameux
awacs dont qui est un avion radar tout
simplement et la coupole que vous avez
au dessus c'est donc le radar de l'avion
qui lui permet de détecter l'ensemble
des dés
l'aéronef qui seraient déployés sur son
théâtre et il est suivi par des mirage
2000 et des rafales spécialisé dans le
combat aérien c'est en plus un bon
moment pour les mirage pour certains
virages comme il ya des mirages qui vont
quitter le service derrag 2000 qui vont
être retirés du service et donc c'est le
dernier défilé on a gardé quelques
heures de vol le potentiel pour eux pour
qu'ils puissent assurer
leur dernier défilé donc
mirage qui était spécialisée justement
dans la défense aérienne
et là nous voyons
ses besoins en transport pour voyager
avec des avions de transport intéressant
est à noter on les verra régulièrement
il sait des avions français mais aussi
des avions de transport d'autres pays à
un acte naturel alors c'est difficile
comme ça de voir les différences mais
voilà il y en a 400 m allemand un a400m
belle jeux de mémoire et un a400m
espagnol en plus d'un quatrième français
dans les quatre gros
quadriréacteur on parle du commandant
tout devant la donc c'est aussi ce
message de fête de solidarité ou pour
certaines missions il est possible
d'aller puiser des heures de vol sur des
à 400m d'autres pays pour réaliser ses
missions suivi de deux 2 c 130j hercules
pardon des appareils plus petits avec
mon c 130 hercules italien voilà voilà
alors on essaie avec ses images de
julien leclercq alors non on vient de là
vous voyez arriver le groupe aérien
embarqué qui vient de repartir mais donc
le groupe aérien embarqué vous voyez
vous avez un avion un peu plus gros que
les autres c'est un avion radar mais
plus petit que le awacs c'est le hawk
eye qui est un avion radar qui peut se
poser sur le charles de gaulle et qui
donc sert à réaliser le contrôle aérien
démission du charles de gaulle et il est
entouré par les huit rafale marine qui
sont déployés aujourd'hui rafale marine
qui sont semblables au rafale de l'armée
de l'air et de l'espace mais avec une
spécificité ils ont une accroche à
l'arrière pour pouvoir accrocher les
brins d'arrêt sur le charles de gaulle
lorsqu'il
la mise quatre nouveaux engins passez
les actus antique 2 pour les trois
premiers et a failli pun de surveillance
maritime derrière donc les atlantique 2
peut-être plus connus ceux qui font la
chasse aux sous marins notamment don qui
ont toute une suite de capteurs de
moyens des lâches des bouées qui sont
capables de tenter de trouver des
signaux dans l'eau pour savoir où sont
les sous-marins donc différents systèmes
qui permettent de tracer ces objets
souvent difficiles à identifier donc les
sous marins ou trois appareils deux
atlantique 2 suivant les prochains
appareils qui arrive c'est la voyez au
loin le box de la formation du personnel
navigant donc avec des avions de
formation formation qui sont réalisés de
manière internationale en france
puisqu'il y a à peu près 200 élèves
pilotes étrangers chaque année qui sont
formés dans les écoles de pilotage
française est donc là vous avez les des
pilatus aidé exigu qui sont qui sont en
train de passer devant vous et qui
démontre un bas qui sont les avions qui
sont utilisés au jour le jour pour
former les pilotes temps de transport
que sur avion de chasse et ensuite nous
devions avoir les avions qui luttent
contre les incendies mais qu'ils ne sont
pas là et alors le
défilé de l'infanterie après laon
terminer la partie du défilé aérien des
appareils est ce qu'il manque
le drone est un drop passe finalement ou
parce que effectivement on n'appelle ne
vient pas et on ne le voit pas sûr sur
les images ce que que que nous avons
actuellement du coup on a besoin que là
on lance le début des défilés c'est
souvent parce qu'il n'y a pas eu le box
avance avec quelquefois un peu compliqué
pour se caler donc quelquefois il ya des
petits arrangements comme ça comme les
pompiers sont allés à des démissions des
vraiment à des missions opérationnelles
ont quelquefois et c'est difficile de
faire des réalignements
sur les missions que pas des adaptations
s'adapter c'est le coeur du métier de
militaire donc voilà quelques fois il ya
ça en moins et on est reparti sur
l'ouverture du défilé à pied s'est rangé
avec l'étrange exactions qui viennent
d'être applaudi ses troupes étrangères
est ce que c'est une habitude justement
doivent être ancrées bienvenue ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas forcément une habitude
et donc c'est un honneur particulier qui
est fait aux l'inflation du forest de
l'otan et de l'europe puisque vous aurez
dans l'ordre la bulgarie coup de vent
suivi par l'estonie et la hongrie
ensuite vous aurez la lituanie la
pologne la tchéquie la roumanie et la
slovaquie donc les petits éléments que
vous avez seul devant sont les portes
emblème de c2c nation est derrière vous
avez un grand carré de troupes qui
rassemble l'ensemble de toutes les
troupes de ces pays un dans le même
carré pour qu'ils puissent défiler de
manière groupée à éviter qu'ils ont été
présentés dans l'ordre alphabétique ya
pas de de plus de donneurs mis à être
devant ou derrière ces voix là c'est une
solidarité
total look l'envoi des uniformes très
bigarré très différents selon les selon
les pays patry camoufler uniforme de
parade ya des traditions militaires
différentes sur selon les pays
quand même un ton uni plutôt tourné vers
le marron et donc un blocs colorés là
aussi à des prix très différents comme
le tri on en parlait tout à l'heure avec
le commandant de la stat c'est aussi
quelque chose au-delà de l'efficacité
opérationnelle c'est aussi un marqueur
identitaire
on repère un militaire ont repéré un
militaire français à son tri centre
europe donc avec ses taches noires verte
aux marrons des générations de
militaires d'appeler autres ont connu
demain le nouveau tri dont on parlait
tout à l'heure sera aussi le marqueur
identitaire identitaire des armées
françaises en france et à l'étranger
nous voyons ces différents pays qui sait
si fientes armées des pays qui défilent
donc des porte drapeaux et après le bloc
uni s'associer au groupe indique qui est
derrière et ils sont par ligne de pas
par pays
priori oui il ya une certaine unité dans
chacune des lignes et pourquoi ils ont
envoyé des représentants de différentes
armes et de ses armées étrangères il
peut avoir un melting-pot mais il ya une
forme d'unité on les repère au béret ou
ou autre et
ou
casquettes vous pouvez le voir puisque
nous avons des casquettes mélanger avec
les bérets alors que au sein des armées
françaises il n'y a que des coiffes
béret pour l'armée de terre donc du coup
vous êtes capable comment vous arrivez à
repérer les liens internationaux alors
je n'en suis pas capable comme ceux ci à
froid mais je me permet de rebondir sur
les troupes que l'on voit donc c'est le
carré des troupes de réassurance à l'est
donc là vous voyez des gens qui ont été
déployés sur le flanc ouest depuis le
mois de février de cette année avec
notamment des gens qui portent des
tartes donc de la 27e brigade
d'infanterie de montagne commandes et
donc devant par le le colonel mag et du
27e bataillon de chasseurs alpins vous
avez aussi dans ses troupes des gens du
4e régiment de chasseurs donc régiment
dans lequel j'ai eu l'honneur de servir
pendant pendant huit ans qui sont des
gens du 3e escadron escadron tout j'ai
aussi eu l'honneur de servir et qui donc
défilent aujourd'hui après être rentré
de roumanie il y a quelques semaines
quels sont les types de missions de ces
hommes est bien la première de toutes
les missions c'est d'être déployés et
prêts à être engagés dans la zone et
ensuite il est réaliste des
entraînements de coopération avec les
armées sur place de manière à pouvoir
être le plus efficace possible s'il y
avait besoin de travailler en
coordination dans la zone et le nouvion
voyons un premier véhicule le général
commandant le défilé des troupes à pied
dont un général que nous avons
qui est qui est un des adjoints du
gouverneur militaire de paris dont nous
parlions tout à l'heure ce qui est
responsable de la défense de la zone de
paris paris et sa couronne sa grande
couronne donc voilà lui les responsables
du défilé à pied et non qu'ils ouvrent
sur son commandant sur son command car
ce défilé et puis nous allons avoir
après traditionnellement le gros bloc
des écoles de formation d'officiers et
de sous-officiers de militaires du rang
et des forces de sécurité qui ont défilé
dans un ordre relativement classique
pour tous les habitués je suis sûr qu'il
y en a derrière les écrans des défilés
là vous pouvez deviner en arrière
l'école polytechnique point particulier
c'est un général polytechnicien le
général ferrié qui au début du siècle à
sauver la tour eiffel du démantèlement
car en développement la télégraphie sans
fil et en utilisant le point haut de la
tour eiffel pour coordonner les
opérations
il l'a démontré l'utilité militaire de
la tour eiffel et nous permet donc de la
voir aujourd'hui plus de cent ans plus
tard pour observer notre défilent
donc classiquement dans ces blocs de des
unités à pied y aura souvent le chef de
la formation le monsieur qui commande
les écoles où celui qui commande la
promotion en tête avec là c'est pas
toujours très simples justement de
défiler tout seul tout devant pour pour
s'allumer et autres en tête et après un
temps de 6 personnes entourant le fanion
l'étang daou le drapeau delà de la
formation donc avec ce qu'on appelle la
gare nos drapeaux donc les six personnes
qui ont été choisis désigné de aussi
c'est un grand honneur d'en faire partie
donc cette gare de drapeaux puis
derrière là aussi des adjoints de ses
responsables et enfin les élèves roues
le gros de la troupe sans être péjoratif
du tout aucunement qui défilent derrière
alignées sur 1 pas hélas est rassurant
120 minutes
exactement entre 115 et 120 minutes qui
est le rythme normal de défilé des
troupes des troupes françaises et nous
verrons un peu plus lent pour la légion
est un peu plus rapide pour les
chasseurs alpins mais je n'en vivrai pas
défiler alors répondu certains c'est
vraiment assez gros quelque chose que
l'on s'entraîne willy a à marcher sur ce
pas très précisément tout à fait
exactement on s'entraîne pendant des
heures et des heures sur des kilomètres
pour que le pas de vienne nature à
l'apprendre et ensuite on se cale sur la
musique qui est là pour permettre de
garder le rythme et si vous écoutez bien
vous entendez une grosse caisse tous les
toutes les quelques secondes et bien
cette grosse caisse nous sert à nous
caler grâce avec notre pied gauche nous
entendons la grosse caisse on tape le
pied gauche par terre et normalement on
est dans le rythme alors comment sont
choisis alors vous pouvez vous dans
l'idée
de la formation de ces échos de la
formation de commissions 10 11 comment
choisit qui va devancer le major de la
promo alors il ya différentes
visuellement il peut avoir différents
choix il peut avoir ce qu'on appelle
former le toit donc c'est à dire prendre
du plus grand au plus petit et faire une
belle pente qui descend une harmonie des
formations quelquefois après il peut
avoir aussi dégradée d'aider des
personnes gradés devant puis après
derrière là aussi un fois à troyes qui
est qui et qui fait donc il ya souvent
différente visuellement pour l'harmonie
pour le message qu'on va envoyer il ya
différentes solutions qui sont choisis
mais généralement la plus allez voir
c'est plutôt les grands devant les
petits derrières
donc une douce pente qui descend et donc
là en revue ces essais tous descendre
puis arriver
alors à la plaza compte se sépare en
deux par deux oui alors elle ne se
sépareront pas tout en deux seules les
grosses unités se sépare car elle ne
pourrait pas manoeuvrer tout entière de
sur un seul virage et vous verrez
certaines unités plus petites qui
partiront entièrement soit sur la droite
ou la gauche et puis nous reviendrons
sur la spécificité de la légion
étrangère qui ne se sépare jamais et
donc qu'ils soient petits grands moyens
ils restent unis alan l'a donc là nous
avons en face de nous de l'école des
officiers de la gendarmerie nationale on
voyait tout à gauche en est une forme un
peu différente couleur verte les
gendarmes espagnol le modèle de
gendarmerie où il est les militaires
s'occupe de missions de sécurité et
parmi eux un modèle si répandue que ça
dans le monde
néanmoins il ya quelques pays par
exemple on pense au mexique qui avait
fondé récemment une gendarmerie mais
aussi en espagne le modèle de
gendarmerie existe et donc il ya des
échanges de professeurs entre les
différentes gendarmerie d'où ce petit
côté bigarrée avec ce genre d'armes
l'espagnol bien connus du cinéma vert et
je me permets d'intervenir puisque là
vous voyez une école chère à mon coeur
l'école spéciale militaire de saint cyr
où j'ai eu l'honneur de servir au début
de ma carrière école créée en 1802 par
napoléon c'est donc traditionnellement
une école qui se déroule en trois ans et
c'est la dernière année le 1er bataillon
qui défilent devant vous aujourd'hui
bataillon de la promotion capitaine en
jeu un qui est donc le capitaine qui a
pris la suite de tom morel 1 au maquis
des glières après la mort de celui ci et
il sera également tués lors des combats
des glières et c'est donc un exemple
qu'a choisi de suivre cette promotion
pour les années de sa présence à saint
cyr mais aussi l'ensemble des années qui
constituera la carrière militaire de
chacun d'entre eux lemoine qui était le
nom d'une promotion entre 87 et 90 aussi
exploiter ou qu'ils nous demandent
pourquoi la roumanie la république
tchèque ont sept soldats qui ont défilé
tandis que d'autres pays n'en avait que
4 vous avez la réponse à cette question
non et voilà nous avons parlé un peu
toutes les réponses aux questions que
vous pouvez essayer de
2,2 trouvé d'école il n'y aura pas il
n'y a pas de souci non pas on ne sait
pas forcément tous vous n'hésitez pas en
tout cas poser vos questions derrière
arrive une école qui est aussi basée là
où est basé l'école spéciale militaire
donc le m il ya l'école militaire
interarmes qui est symbolique aussi deux
dents pour important dans les armées
cette capacité ce qu'on appelle
l'escalier social cette capacité a
commencé militaires du rang et par le
mérite par les concours par la formation
a grimpé donc et à monter en grade et à
être reconnu et est reconnu pour sa
surtout et le m il ya donc l'école
militaire interarmes c'est des
militaires du rang et des sous-officiers
qui après un début de carrière passe un
concours
pour devenir officier et donc il ya une
école dédiée donc souvent des personnes
qui ont déjà 3 4 en 5 ans d'expérience
nous qui sont passés pas une formation
initiale pour eux et qu'ils rejoignent
donc cette école de formation pour
compléter leur première formation leur
première expérience et ensuite repartir
dans leurs unités comme officier donc
très symbolique de cette capacité des
armées ou pour faire rapidement il ya
des tiers il ya un tiers de un tiers de
militaires du rang qui vont passer
sous-officier un tir de sous-officiers
qui vont passer au dessus donc voilà
bref escalier social n'est pas forcément
similaires partout dans la société ou en
tout cas on peut grimper par le mérite
et par concours formation et autres
c'est ce qu'on voit que tu aimes tout à
fait et derrière est ce que c'est la
même école ou sans notes et donc
derrière vous voyez l'école militaire
des aspirants de quoi de qui dans donc
qui forme les officiers sous contrat de
l'armée de l'armée de terre qui est une
école et qui est très récente puisque la
formation des officiers sous contrat et
est très ancien mais cette école a été
créée en 2021 et donc elles défilent
pour la deuxième fois cette année et
vous voyez la couleur de leur costume
bleu horizon bleu horizon pour rappeler
les combats et les sacrifices de la
grande guerre de la première guerre
mondiale
dont il dont ils gardent l'esprit
circuit franchement les uniformes sont
très jolis effectivement il faut que ces
uniformes ils changent beaucoup selon
les écoles où on est sur des traditions
et tous les éléphants n'ont pas bougé
depuis 50 ans alors écoutez pour l'école
spéciale militaire de saint-cyr
l'uniforme n'a pas bougé depuis plus de
100 ans donc
donc c'est un uniforme qui caractérise
les élèves de cette école à travers les
décennies voire des siècles et qui
participe finalement à une cohésion un
échange un sentiment un sentiment
d'appartenance des élèves et des
militaires au sens plus large alors on à
lucien qui le demandent combien alors
dissuader les soldats français sont au
nombre de combien alors je sais pas si
c'est pendant ce défilé ou si c'est en
général hors écouter j'aurai les deux
réponses sur ce défilé vous avez six
mille trois cents militaires de
l'ensemble des armées et des services
qui défilent et ensuite vous avez sur
l'ensemble des armées à peu près de 110
mille deux cent dix mille soldats et une
soixantaine de milliers de civils de la
défense qui travaille aussi au sein du
ministère des armées pour arriver à un
effectif global de 270000 personnel du
ministère après le bloc des écoles liées
plus tôt à l'armée de terre se présente
là on voit déjà l'école de l'école de
l'armée de l'air juste avant il y avait
l'école navale
donc ce qui forme les officiers de la
marine nationale à brest au bout de la
bretagne et puis juste après l'école de
l'air et de l'espace donc là aussi cette
petit changement commence à un petit peu
à s'y faire l'école l'école l'armée de
l'air s'appelait armée de l'air jusqu'à
il ya encore deux trois ans deux ans et
a pris ce ajoutée et de l'espace temps
les combats les les menaces et les
risques en provenance de l'espace sont
importants et nous aurons la défense des
intérêts français pour les satellites
les communications l'observation et
autres en sont importants et donc
l'armée de l'air s'est saisie de cette
mission une mission qu'il menait déjà
depuis quelques années et le conte
changé lors des nominations lors des
nominations
pardon et s'appelle donc écoles de l'air
et de l'espace do d'où ce petit
changement dans la on les voit à l'écran
du côté de salon de provence est ce que
ça veut dire que c est que la médiane de
l'espace
entraîne des militaires à être en
condition d'être dans l'espace
finalement alors ça oui alors c'est très
j'allais dire anecdotique c'est
peut-être péjoratif ya que quelques ya
peu d'élus 1 mais plus globalement les
combattants de l'espace ceux qui sont
liés au commandement de commandement de
l'espace ont des démissions peut-être
moins visuel que 1 thomas pesquet qui
part dans les fusées et autres mais tout
ce qui est la gestion des satellites la
protection des fruits de communication
entre un satellite de communication et
le sol la récupération des images des
observations qui sont faites par des
satellites d'observation tout ça est
géré par ces militaires même les
manoeuvres des satellites comme les
satellites aujourd'hui au delà de faire
des tours autour de l'espace peuvent
être bougé par rapport à pour avoir la
meilleure vue pour avoir le meilleur
positionnement pour éviter même des
satellites et demi tout ça c'est une des
missions tout à fait du commandement de
l'espace une entité qui monte en
puissance actuellement du côté de
toulouse avec nouveau bâtiment qui
sortent de de terre et autres donc un
vrai effort français en se disant que
tout français dont dans votre téléphone
ici dans votre internet et autres
utilisent votre voiture utilise
plusieurs satellites par jour et donc il
ya une vraie question il ya un vrai
enjeu de défense et de gérer des
opérations dans cet espace comment vous
y rajouter quelque chose eh bien écoutez
je crois que total et eni qui justement
en terme de deux satellites et on a des
satellites de défense parce qu'on sait
combien d' alors écoutez nous avons
actuellement des satellites
d'observation spatiale qui sont rénovés
la capacité spatiale opérationnel donc
qui ont commencé à être envoyés depuis
ces dernières années qui relève des
satellites qui était déjà déjà dans
l'espace donc avec une capacité
d'observation et de détails bien
supérieure à ce que l'on avait avant on
a aussi des satellites de
télécommunications qui permettent
d'avoir des communications sécurisées
chiffrés pour nos troupes en opération
et vers la métropole et bien sûr en
interne sur sur la métropole et nous
avons aussi des satellites de détection
de rayonnement électromagnétique pour
détecter par exemple des radars ou des
stations d'émission d'autres adversaires
potentiels et demain on va dire dans
quelques années il y aura des satellites
de défense donc un projet qui est qui
est menée par l'agencé innovation de
défense de petits satellites qui vont
tenter de protéger des plus gros
satellite par des manoeuvres par des
blues satellite adverse se ce col et
voilà tout c'est encore des projets
assez initiaux et voilà des projets
peut-être un peu star wars et pourtant
qui dans quelques années seront seront
bien concret donc pour défendre les
quelques satellites alors qu'en fait il
ya une question de nombre il y en a pas
tant que ça donc défini son précieux
temps là que nous avons
perdu le fil je crois que c'est l'école
de la gendarmerie exactement vous avez
l'école des sous-officiers de la
gendarmerie nationale un don qui
défilent actuellement il faut savoir que
la gendarmerie nationale est une est une
armée qui qui comporte majoritairement
des sous-officiers puisque le grade de
gendarme est un grade et ça correspond
au grade de sergent au sein au sein des
autres armées donc la majeure partie des
gendarmes que que nous pouvons côtoyé
sont des sous-officiers est ce qui est
intéressant c'est l'école de
sous-officiers de dijon une école
nouvelle qui a été construite récemment
du fait de la remontée en puissance des
effectifs des armées poste attentats de
la gendarmerie poste attentats n'ont
qu'une école récente à dijon et qui à la
petite spécificité d'avoir un nom
l'école chef d'escadron gastro merde et
qu'elle a peut-être petite spécificité
d'être à la fois aviateurs et gendarmes
durant la durant la première guerre
mondiale il a été gendarme mobile +
aviateurs a amené des combats dans le
ciel est en fait cette école s'est
inscrite dans une ancienne base aérienne
française donc un peu cette filiation
entre le côté gendarmes aujourd'hui et
aviation hier donc voilà d'où le nom
d'où le nom qui a été pris vous voyez
défier l'école nationale des
sous-officiers d'actifs dont qui forme
les sous-officiers de l'armée de terre
le corps des sous-officiers de l'armée
de terre est formé de manière initiale à
saint maixent dans cette école mais il
retourne aussi régulièrement au cours de
sa carrière pour être prêts à prendre
les responsabilités qui évolue bien
évidemment au fus de la carrière cette
école est traditionnellement celle qui
défilent le mieux comment ça de
l'ensemble des troupes de du défilé du
défilé à pied s'est c'est quelque chose
sur lequel ils font un effort
particulier est donc les sous-officiers
de l'armée de terre sont très attachés
au défilé de laine soie c'est à dire
qu'il s'entraîne plus et du coup ils
sont mal vus par les autres parce que je
ne sors pas mal vu par les autres ils
sont ils sont appréciés par les autres
car en nous savons nous savons le prix
qu'il ya à payer pour défiler
parfaitement sur les champs elysées mais
ces officiers quelles que soient les
arrêts sont vraiment la colonne
vertébrale des armées c'est vraiment ce
qu'ils sont entre les la tête eh ben on
va dire et éléments donc voilà c'est des
courroies de transmission très important
le rôle du sous-officier quelles que
soient les armes et songe est vraiment
important de nageurs c'est souvent plus
des personnes qui sont des lieux très
longue carrière pour certains d'entre
eux qui font qu'ils sont la mémoire des
unités qui sont ceux par qui le
commandant passe pour faire passer le
message le rôle de sous-officiers
vraiment un rôle d'importance dans les
armées
là vous voyez passer l'école de
formation des sous-officiers de la
marraine donc l'école de maistrance qui
forment les sous-officiers marinier qui
serviront sur les navires mais aussi les
sous marins et les bases de la marine
nationale
cd et des différentes écoles nationales
de 2 sauf ici il ya plusieurs blocs on
voit de tout à fait chaque armée à
assat intégrer sa formation internaliser
sa formation pour ses spécificités au
delà du métier de combattants comme très
vite y ait des questions souvent
techniques quand même qu'ils
apparaissent selon les milieux dans
lequel il opère et donc chaque armée
voilà détient ces écoles de formation
pour les différents niveaux on a
remarqué mme mendes que la légion
étrangère défilent aussi oui la légion
étrangère va défilé est
traditionnellement elle fermera le
défilé à pied car la légion étrangère
des filins a pas plus lent que les
autres unités nous avons dit tout à
l'heure 115 20 minutes pour les unités
régulières et bien la légion étrangère
défi la 88e minute et donc légitimement
nous les mettons un dernier pour qu'ils
puissent défiler alors pas sans
perturber ou des films 100 g 2 et ils
défilent doucement c'est comme il aime
bien les applaudissements il aime bien
prendre leur temps ils selon vous verrez
ils sont très applaudie donc ils vont
prendre le temps de profiter de tous ces
applaudissements qui sont souvent
généralement mûri tony voilà les
chasseurs alpins ils ont le combat
n'attend pas donc ils défient beaucoup
plus vite et il faut qu'ils aillent il
faut qu'ils aillent au combat voilà les
petites anecdotes
quelquefois qui ont rêvé la vérité
historique et quelquefois un peu
trafiqué là dessus mais voilà c'est les
petites explications qui sont donnés
alors nous étions avant avec l'école de
formation des sous-officiers de l'armée
de l'air et de l'espace
et puis sans sur les images l'école des
mousses
pense on voit le reste le chef
du bloc on va voir oui voilà c'est ça vu
le pompon le col caractéristiques
nous sommes bien face à l'école des
mousses une école de formation où les
jeunes peuvent rentrer dès 16 ans si je
me trompe pas vraiment effectivement on
va retrouver d'ailleurs timothée
timothée qui est qu'ils toujours sur
place sur les champs-elysées qu'on voit
les troupes défilaient derrière lui
timothée comment ces différentes troupes
sont sont accueillis acclamé par les
parisiens qui sont à côté de vous
eh bien écoutez oui tout à fait le
défilé l'acquis qui se poursuit un juste
derrière nous je rappelle que nous
sommes au niveau de la place clemenceau
vraiment au milieu des champs elysées et
les troupes qui sont accueillis dans une
ambiance
très très disciplinés en fait les gens
qui sont heureux de devoir les
militaires passaient devant eux vraiment
à quelques quelques petits mètres de
quelques applaudissements qui sortent de
la foule mais pas non plus des
applaudissements extrêmement extrêmement
nourris je le disais tout à l'heure
lorsque lorsqu'emmanuel macro le chef de
l'état est passé juge devant nous
c'était pareil il y avait une ambiance
très calme bien là c'est un petit peu la
même chose qui se passe est ce que la
chaleur peut être eu raison de l'énergie
de
la foule qui est venue ce matin je ne
sais pas en tout les cas voilà une
ambiance très disciplinés les gens qui
sont assez a concentré qui regardent les
troupes des filets quelques
applaudissements mais pas non plus de
très grands nomura on entend en tout cas
la fanfare qui se situe vraiment au
niveau de la tribune officielle plus
près de là de la place de la concorde 1
qui qui couvrent voilà un petit peu nos
voix nos échanges et les gens qui
continuent petit à petit de voir ce
défilé qui se déroule pour l'instant
sous de très bons auspices
[Musique]
les dalles bord d'un hélicoptère
actuellement alors que ces images
reviennent de figer alors c'est toujours
très compliqué d'arriver à filmer
forcément au-dessus de paris avec des
moyens de communication on peut
peut-être en parler avec vous dire
comment on dire arriver à établir une
liaison au dessus de paris il ya
quelques petits problèmes notamment lors
du 14 juillet eh bien écoutez c'est un
métier c'est d'ailleurs l'objet d'une
arme entière au sein de l'armée terre
lors des transmissions qui fête ses 80
ans cette année donc vous verrez défiler
différents différents blocs et donc qui
a pour mission d'assurer la liaison
entre l'ensemble des unités déployées en
opérations et si aujourd'hui nous
n'arrivons pas à voir l'image de
l'hélicoptère je dirais que le risque
est tout de même finalement assez minime
sur son impact mais en opération si
jamais nous perdons la liaison les
risques sont bien différents et donc
c'est tout l'objet de cette arme qui
nous permet d'être coordonnée efficace
en permanence alors là nous devons
terminer les écoles militaires et bien
c'est
une petite spécificité pour cette année
c'est en effet le commandement de la
cyber gendarmes la suède a dû
cyberespace de la gendarmerie pardon
donc une première pour eux des gendarmes
là on parlait de l'espace tout à l'heure
et là le cyber un autre milieu où les
risques et les menaces ne font que
s'amplifier donc des gendarmes qui sont
spécialisés à la fois pour la lutte par
exemple pour la pédocriminalité pour
tout ce qui est vie russe extorsion de
fonds et autres ransomware et autres
donc des gendarmes qui sont spécialisés
sur ce sur ses missions qui est qui
voient leur mission explosé en nombre
ces dernières années les chiffres sont
colossaux
tout à chacun qui a sont
tous ces équipements numériques voilà
viser les généraux des choses plus
compliquées sur les entreprises avec des
systèmes bloqué commandement de la cyber
et du cyberespace de la gendarmerie donc
c'est une première sur les champs oui ça
parce que on qu'on parle qu'on parle
défilé militaire on pense voilà
militaires sur le terrain en opération
extérieure alors dans les images en
direct avec julien leclercq qui est dans
un hélicoptère ou le rappel d'un
hélicoptère qui va défiler le défilé des
hélicoptères est prévu normalement si
tout se passe bien aux alentours de
11h30
mais comme vous voyez en nous avons
toujours avoir là on n'a pas à notre
d'autres troubles là vous avez
actuellement la musique des troupes de
marine qui défilent alors nous avons
nous n'avons pas vu passer les
commandants les généraux commandant les
troupes de marine mais cette année je
vous interromps juste parce qu'on a les
images devient le coeur et on voit ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure les
différents
appareils qui sont là et qui attendent
en fait de passer staff technique qui
stationnent à côté de paris voilà qui
font leur hippodrome donc comme on le
disait voilà qu'ils vont faire des pour
un peu désaxé part au défilé pour pas
gêné
ils ont déjà commencé à former leur bloc
on les voit on les voyait tout à l'heure
les hélicoptères qui seront devant les
hélicoptères de votre journaliste allait
de ses 135 de la gendarmerie et qu'ils
vont attendre patiemment le top départ
pour aller sortir de livres prod'homme
s'aligner et profiter de ce moment qui a
500 km heure et autres dur vraiment
quelques secondes on imagine qu on fait
plutôt ça avec les hélicoptères qu'avec
les réseaux de chasse parce que c'est
plus compliqué de les garder
stationnaire en la voyant l'air voilà
les avions de chasse le fond plus loin
le fondant au delà la région parisienne
font là aussi des hippodromes y en a il
y en a un de mémoire en normandie un
autre plus au sud de là au sud voilà ils
font des grands hippodromes des grands
cercles comme ça en attendant le top
départ depuis leur base aérienne surtout
que ces derniers temps pour faciliter la
sphère il décolle souvent de leurs bases
aériennes là où ils sont basés au
quotidien pour certains ça peut être
l'homme beware mont-de-marsan pour
d'autres luxeuil et autres
quelquefois ils se réunissent du côté
d'evreux qui est quand même passivement
que ça mais voilà il s'aligne tous sur
ces hippodromes et au top on sortira et
on salue n'y aura sur les champs donc
ses dribbles avant 11h30 et nous verrons
si tu vois là oui là vous voyez défiler
les troupes de marine comme je le disais
tout à l'heure qui fêtent leurs 400 ans
cette année donc créé en 1622 par le le
cardinal richelieu
originellement pour prendre garnison à
bord des navires de la flotte française
et des bases et donc c'est une
faites de 400 aujourd'hui donc nous
avons beaucoup de régiments des troupes
de marine qui défile c'est le plus gros
bloc 1 qui défilera qui défilera
aujourd'hui les troupes de marine
désormais ont une vocation à servir
outre-mer et à l'étranger un au service
au service de la france mais aussi sur
l'ensemble des opérations
régulières comme l'ensemble du reste de
l'armée de terre actuellement vous devez
voir le 3e régiment parachutiste
d'infanterie de marine qui est basée à
carcassone donc vous pouvez les
reconnaître avec leurs bérets rouges qui
sont à la caractéristique des des
parachutistes dans l'armée de terre
française
et donc ils sont spécialistes des
actions aéroportée et c'est donc de la
fente riz légère légère on comprend pour
pouvoir être embarqués dans les avions
et combattre avec peu de moyens qu'une
fois qu'ils ont été largués on a vu dire
des des épaulettes des polices courage
et alain
sur les épaules donc les fourragères on
repère le terme de fourrage donc les à
l'époque
il ya quelques siècles servait à
approcher le fourrage des chevaux
c'était une fille ciel qui lui
permettait de faire un noeud et on
accrochait le fourrage et chevaux
aujourd'hui la symbolique est tout autre
chaque couleur représente généralement
une décoration qui a reçu le régiment ou
limitées donc des médailles la croix de
guerre et la médaille militaire et
autres et des médailles plutôt
prestigieuses sont portés par les hommes
des ses différents régiments donc il y
en a qui peuvent en avoir 2 3 selon les
couleurs des selon la couleur des
médailles reçues parce que autant des
personnes peuvent être félicités et
récompensés à titre individuel mais
aussi à l'humanité entière qui peut
recevoir une décoration ces derniers
temps typiquement par exemple des croix
de la valeur militaire donc une
décoration plutôt prestigieuses qui a
été remise un grand nombre de régiments
pour des actions qui ont été menées en
centrafrique il ya quelques années hélas
les décorations sont en train de tomber
là nous ayons les cookies actuellement
je pense que c'est une gamine qui en
beauté noire c'est une caméra qui est
plus grave puisque les pompiers sont
sont plus en arrière sur le sur le
défilé et vous allez voir défiler de
nombreuses troupes avant de les voir
arriver devant la tribune présidentielle
actuellement devant le devant la tribune
nous avons la fin du du groupe d des
blindés de marine donc le régiment
d'infanterie-chars de marine et le 1er
régiment d'infanterie de marine qui
viennent de défiler et derrière vous
avez normalement le blog de l'artillerie
de marine donc de l'artillerie de marine
avec le 3ème régiment d'artillerie et le
11e régiment d'artillerie de marine tous
deux qu'ils servent sur canon caesar un
canon caesar et mortiers de 120 mm les
bigors en souvenir donc des bigorneaux
les coquillages qui s'accrochent au kop
des des bateaux parce qu'ils étaient
troupes de marine en fait c'étaient des
hommes qui combattait en mer mais qui
étaient embarqués sur les navires de la
royal mail qu'ils étaient un peu comme
des bigorneaux accroché comme une moule
approché à son rocher donc d'où ce
surnom de bigorre pour les artilleurs de
marine et juste avant c'était les
marsouins lorsque tous ceux qui font 9 c
est parti de l'infanterie de la
cavalerie d' des troupes de marine bima
reçoivent donc ces animaux qu'il a aussi
sauté à côté des navires est un combat
qui est mené à bien lors des trajets là
aussi c'était voilà c'était il avait
besoin d'un navire de la royal mais il
essayait de quitter dès qu'ils pouvaient
servir pour aller combattre au sol voilà
donc les marsouins et les bigors alors
voilà on va retrouver ces images vous
avez vu juste avenue devient leclerc qui
fait de filmer deux indicateurs ce qui
n'est pas facile avec l'adhésion qui est
loin du sol donc forcément c'est parfois
plus combien en vous parlant de liaison
vous avez là le bloc des transmissions
qui défilent en l'honneur en l'honneur
de son de son anniversaire donc avec en
tête le général commandant les systèmes
d'information et de communication
de l'armée de terre qui sera suivi par
le général commandant l'école des
transmissions et ensuite vous verrez
défiler les emblèmes de 4 régiment de
transmissions qui non plus envoyé que
leur emblème et après vous aurez des
régiments qui eux ont eu l'honneur de
pouvoir venir constituer sur sur les
champs vous voyez que les emblèmes sont
baissés devant le président à son
passage c'est la seule occasion à
laquelle les emblèmes donc les drapeaux
ou étendard des unités sont baissées
donc la transmission larmes qui relie
les arbres tous ceux qui s'occupent des
raisons qu'ils soient internet de plus
tactique de radio de satellites et
autres
on sait aujourd'hui que le combat
moderne ne se fait pas sans ses moyens
ces moyens de réseaux et de
communication qui sont à courte distance
mais quelquefois à plusieurs milliers de
kilomètres entre les opérations et la
métropole donc des techniciens souvent
de très haut niveau qui m'a guidée des
matériels de plus en plus sophistiquées
qui au quotidien perdre perdre la
liaison ça peut se révéler compliquée
même si les militaires apprennent à
combattre sans s'appuyer son système
plus serein et plus facile d'avoir la
liaison qui passe d'où les efforts
constants de tous ces transmetteurs pour
maintenir le maintenir le lien tout à
fait donc là vous voyez les 41e et 53e
régiment de transmissions qui sont les
régiment de transmissions sur la charge
d'assurer comme l'a dit mon camarade la
liaison entre les unités sur le théâtre
pour que les unités puisse parler en
talent mais aussi le théâtre et la
métropole pour que les centres
d'opération notamment le centre de
planification et de conduite des
opérations sous les ordres du chef
d'état-major des armées puissent donner
les ordres qu'il a donné que ce soit en
afrique au moyen-orient ou à l'autre
bout du pacifique oui c'est quelque
chose qu'on a peut-être tendance un peu
oubliée alors que là on est beaucoup
plus une nouvelle fois sur les champs
voilà mais on voit
commandos marine le provost la rime avec
des chiffres qui les régit les chiens le
chien du commando kieffer généralement
donc il ya un commando spécialisés pour
pour l'appui technique aux autres
commandos plus que gère le le geste
final des opérations donc là on est
reparti sur le régiment du train là
aussi une spécifique spécialité très
importante au sein de l'armée de terre
double régiment qui s'occupe de tous les
mouvements logistique ou pas forcément
on appelle régiment du train n'est pas
forcément
juste avoir une vision ferroviaire de de
la faire et voilà et qui mène des
manoeuvres compliqué aujourd'hui
notamment on pense au sahel ou
le démantèlement de l'opération aube
arcanes conduit à faire des grands
mouvements de marchandises le véhicule
et autres et donc c'est des régiments
comme ça la logistique militaire autour
des régiment du train notamment qui font
des grandes valeurs d'émission très
importante de la logistique suivent le
régiment que vous avez vu défiler le
121e régiment du train qui tous les ans
participe au soutien du 14 juillet
puisque il est basé à montlhéry et cette
année il a l'honneur en plus de
participer au soutien de défilé lui-même
sur les champs ce qui est un grand
honneur vous voyez là la brigade des
sapeurs pompiers de paris dont qui est
une unité du génie de l'armée de terre
de l'armée de terre mais qui sert pour
emploi au ministère de l'intérieur et
sous les ordres de la préfecture de
police de paris et qui donc a sur
l'ensemble des missions de secours
d'intervention sur incendie au sein de
la ville de paris et de la petite
couronne
[Musique]
alors là on retrouve les images
justement vous regardez ces images on
voit qu'elle fige on peut le dire il ya
aussi des débrouillards au dessus des
vagues et que c'est pas fera de ces
pistes pratiques de d'abord des
connexions fiables comme ça au dessus de
paris sur toi 14 juil oui tout à fait
puisque l'appel de défense de défense
aérienne pour le sud paris et une double
proposé également du radar et les ondes
radar sont des ondes radio qui peuvent
tout à fait brouiller les flux les flux
que nous recevons de ces de ses
hélicoptères ou avions
retourne du côté des filets avec monaco
on le voit sur le ban images portent les
premiers portent une hache lahrache du
sapeur pompiers ont cassé la porte pour
rentrer
aller chercher la personne qui est
qui est prise en incendie donc
au-delà du symbole il finit un peu de
l'arme du génie de l'armée sammer qui
devait être en première ligne pour
casser les c pour casser les obstacles
et laissez passer là le reste de la
troupe du mois 7 h symbolique des
sous-officiers de la brigade des sapeurs
pompiers de pâques là vous voyez défiler
l'équipage de la frégate de défense
aérienne forbin donc qui est une frégate
de classe horizon et dont la mission est
comme le nom l'indiqué d'effectuer la
défense aérienne des regroupements
maritime français mais aussi grâce à ces
radar très perfectionné d'assurer la
coordination de la manoeuvre aériennes
alliées lorsqu'elle est déployé au sein
au sein d'un détachement c'est à dire
que frégate de défense aérienne il se
défendre des attaques aériennes
exactement ils ont un certain nombre de
missiles anti aériens qui sont là pour
détruire soit les missiles soit les
avions adverses qui souhaiteraient
attaque et principalement les gros
bâtiments de la flotte c'est à dire le
charles de gaulle où les autres frégates
de premier rang quand charles de gaulle
est d'aider des pays on imagine que du
coup il ya ses frigos exactement il ya
des frégates de défense aérienne aux
côtés du charles de gaulle en permanence
il y a aussi un sous marin nucléaire
d'attaqué de combat donc qui protège le
charles de gaulle sous les mers et vous
avez des frégates de lutte
anti-sous-marine également autour du
portable est derrière
on parlait des gros missiles coréen
on allait en commentaire donc là nous
avons ce qui peut s'en rapprocher le
plus c est encore c'est le sous marin
nucléaire lanceur d'engins le téméraire
l'équipage de ce sous-marin nucléaire
qui participent à la dissuasion
nucléaire française
voilà qui défilent aujourd'hui sur les
champs il s'agit des 50 ans de la
première cette année marque les 50 ans
de la première patrouille de dissuasion
nucléaire maritime il faut savoir qu'il
ya en permanence au moins un sous-marin
nucléaire lanceur de missiles nucléaires
français à la mer etc sous laon deux
équipages pour être en permanence
capable de partir de partir en opération
et cdu six mois six mois alors non les
missions en général des sous-marins dure
soixante dix jours 70 jours plus ou
moins suivant suivant la situation pour
elle mais on comprend bien que que si on
peut l'éviter on ne va pas laisser six
mois enfermé nos personnels sans aucune
sans aucune preuve bien évidemment si
l'opération olympique il resterait le
temps nécessaire
au sol on va retourner du côté de des
champs elysées avec timothée timothée
comment se passe ce que ce défilé qu'est
ce que vous avez à côté de lui
eh bien écoutez nous on a une foule
assez nombreuse là qui est toujours à
massés à proximité des militaires qui
sont en train de dérouler une foule je
vous le disais tout à l'heure très
disciplinés à la bataille de
l'applaudimètre c'est clairement la
brigade des sapeurs-pompiers de paris
qui qui a été la plus applaudie tout
alors lorsqu'elle est passée juste
devant nous et puis voilà quelques
applaudissements également bien sûr pour
pour les autres militaires qui défilent
mais voilà une foule toujours toujours
assez assez calme mais qui qui regarde
avec plaisir beaucoup de sourires on
voit sur les sur les visages qui
regardent avec beaucoup de plaisir donc
ce ce défilé qui se poursuit là on
entend quelques quelques pourra juste
juste derrière nous et puis je vous le
disais tout à l'heure les plusieurs
unités également la légion étrangère qui
se préparaient également à rentrer dans
ce dans ce défilé militaire la fanfare
qui continue de résonner bien sûr un
proximité de quelques mètres de nous nos
niveaux de la place clemenceau je le
rappelle locaux milieu des champs
elysées et on attend maintenant le
défilé des hélicoptères qui devrait
arriver d'une minute à l'autre
effectivement merci timothée les
hélicoptères qui devrait arriver
11h31 mais le défilé a pris un peu de
retard a priori donc ça devrait être un
peu plus tard peut-être dix minutes 10
minutes de retard
j'avais une question que j'ai reperdu
entre temps le nombre de
régiments qui est qui qui défilent alors
écoutez je n'ai pas la réponse la
réponse comme ça sous la main mais vous
avez au moins 25 à 30 unités qui vont
défiler à pied auquel il faut rajouter
l'ensemble des unités aériennes et est
mécanisé et je pense que l'on doit
avoisiner les 70 unités défilant
aujourd'hui mais ça reste à confirmer
alors nous avons les images toujours au
dessus ces termes je vous rappel c'est
quand même compliqué de filmée depuis un
hélicoptère qui bouffe c'est pas très
stable forcément des mille collines à
quoi servira c'est un miracle sans cesse
renouveler les ingénieurs voulions
depuis l'hélicoptère jeu qui comprennent
comment ça marche surtout des doigts
voir supplanter normalement voilà entre
le fait n'est seront de l'arrière là le
retour de que leurs auteurs le rotor au
dessus c'est quand même d un objet
complexe et même si la grande capacité
justement à faire du vol stationnaire là
ce qu'il ne faut pas forcément qui fit
qui le différencie des des avions ça
reste un objet extrêmement de compliquer
les défiant
la vous venez de voir défiler la base
aérienne 106 de bordeaux mérignac et on
devine juste derrière et bien voilà au
centre désormais la base aérienne 942 de
lyon mont verdun le point particulier de
cette base aérienne c'est qu'elle abrite
le commandement de la défense aérienne
et des opérations et des opérations de
l'armée de l'air et c'est de cette base
que l'ensemble des opérations aériennes
des armées françaises sur l'ensemble du
globe est contrôlé et commandes et donc
même si les avions sont déployés par
exemple on ira à face ont déployé en
jordanie ou en eau en afrique ils sont
commandés depuis la base aérienne de
mont verdun c'est la base centrale
finalement exaltante qui est qui et qui
résume tout avec une base un peu
particulière qui est enterré donc il ya
des kilomètres et des kilomètres de
galeries
voilà une base
voilà avec des longs corridors enterré
assez impressionnante à avoir comme
infrastructure là on est plus haut sur
les jambes des idées donc on est moins
sous le doigt est sans doute du côté des
commissaires de police je pense voilà on
est en haut des plusieurs qui fait le
défilé comme disait le commandant tout à
l'heure ce sur plusieurs kilomètres donc
là on voyait les petits mouvements de
recalage des rythmes l'objectif est bien
arrivé en rythme tout en bas mais en
haut on peut voir se recaler accélérer
ralentir envoyez leur un moment un
mouvement sur place tout en haut c'est
tout une voix là toute la mécanique est
mise pour que le
cela soit parfait surtout tout en vain
on peut se planter un petit peu euros et
plus du tout en bas on peut dire ça
comme ça on peut dire ça
n'hésitez pas en tout cas dans les
commentaires à poser vos questions on
hésite toujours d'y répondre au mieux à
ce qui est intéressant là il ya un bloc
très intéressant et très particulier
pour lequel les militaires doivent
beaucoup c'est le blog du service de
santé des armées de l'extrême avant donc
l'extrême marrant parce que les
infirmiers mes médecins militaires et
autres vont jusqu en première ligne
s'occuper des blessés
réalise hélas trop souvent des miracles
quasi quotidiens sur sur des blessés de
guerre fortement touchés nous placer ses
des unités qui vont céder médecins
militaires des infirmiers des
secouristes qui vont au combat avec les
autres unités est en première ligne
s'occuper de
grave blessés ou aussi la bobologie
comme on pourrait dire du quotidien de
la fif lu et de la coupure de la brûlure
du coup de soleil et autres voilà des
compétences
ils ont souvent des compétences très
concentré et plus étoffé que des
peut-être des médecins civils parce
qu'ils doivent être quelquefois dans des
positions très éloignées très isolée
faire des miracles
un remettre maintenir en vie et autres
donc d
des hommes et des femmes sur lequel
commence à l'avant qui vont jusque là
remise en sur pied des blessés qui
peuvent durer très très longtemps les
amputés et les grands brûlés donc ils
font vraiment un miracle un travail tout
à fait remarquable
je peux vous confirmer puisque lorsque
l'on est déployé au combat le médecin et
l'infirmier qui les accompagnent
bénéficie d'une attention particulière
de l'ensemble de l'ensemble des gens des
gens de l'unité puisqu'on sait que sont
nos anges gardiens et et pour les avoir
vus je vous confirme qu'elle sont
capables de réaliser des miracles
vraiment des miracles en opération et
fnac alors on est alors pourquoi ces
images qui sont en direct on vous
rappelle qu'elle peut figer de temps en
temps les légataires qui vont passer
d'ici un petit mot t-rex qui donnent
tous qu on utilise tout encore des famas
dans l'armée alors eh bien écoutez nous
utilisons encore des famas dans l'armée
parce que il devait y sont toujours et
toujours d'actualité est opérationnel
mais si vous le notez bien l'armée de
terre change son fusil d'assaut depuis
quelques années maintenant et le
remplace par le hk 416 qui a vocation à
voir remplacer l'ensemble des pharmacies
de l'armée de terre d'ici d'ici la fin
de la décennie donc actuellement en
opération extérieure particulièrement en
bande sahélo saharienne vous n'avez plus
de femmes à se déployer au sein de
l'armée tiers mais uniquement des à
julia 416 animé que ça prend du temps de
te reposer tout un stop par un autre
actuellement ça prend ça prendra pour
l'armée de terre à peu près 7 à 8 ans
donc là nous sommes en haut des
champs-elysées et on peut la soupe au
lait
repérer les sapeurs de la légion
étrangère donc avec le tanneur avec 3 3
éléments constitutifs le tablier en cuir
pour se protéger des barbelés donc ils
avaient vocation à monter à l'assaut en
première ligne donc les les bases pour
se protéger des barbelés éviter des
loupés la hache pour couper ses ces
mêmes barbelés faire le passage et puis
la barbe la varde le symbole de l'ancien
de celui qui de la force tranquille du
vétéran qui est ici connaît qui si on
lui fait plus et donc qu'ils ont gardé
cette barre mais il ya chaque année un
peu un des sélections au sein de la
légion de celui qui aura la plus belle
barbe en tout cas la barbe méritent de
rentrer dans cette section de saveurs et
des clés en tête de l'année comme
étrangère aussi toujours en tête voilà
et sa peur parce que côté là le côté on
n'a pas trop loin de faire du longboard
et bien écoutez
s'il n'y a pas d'interdiction de port de
la barbe le plan de la barre est laissée
à la diligence de chaque de chaque chef
la seule conduite à tenir ce sont des
conditions opérationnelles et bien
évidemment par exemple pour les masques
à gaz que l'on utilise en cas d'attaqué
chimique ou autre il faut bien
évidemment que si barbie liale soit
assez courte pour que le masque reste
étanche sinon il n'y aurait aucun
intérêt à le porter
là nous sommes plus sur les militaires
et les forces de sécurité qui défilent
elle aussi avec l'école nationale de
police
de rouen qui est devant vous sur les
images donc différentes écoles de police
en france pour former les policiers donc
celle de rouen avec en tête les
commissaires qu'on reconnaît à les
charmes tricolore sainte autour de leur
taille
[Musique]
donc là on parle bien de la police
nationale
et non des unités de la police
municipale ici l'année dernière
unité de la police municipale des filets
unité de la police nationale qui seront
suivis par l'école nationale supérieure
des sapeurs-pompiers
donc à à paris il ya des mines et à
paris notamment à marseille il ya des
unités militaires de sapeurs pompiers le
bataillon de marins pompiers et le
bataillon des sapeurs pompiers de paris
mais dans le reste de la france le
modèle qu'ils aient choisi est celui de
sapeurs pompiers ou professionnels ou
volontaires est en tout cas pour le
corps des officiers il ya une école de
formation particulière avec souvent des
formations de très haut niveau comme au
delà de la cie déjà la lutte contre les
incendies les bobos du quotidien sont
très exigeants ils sont aussi des
formations dans l'est des risques
nucléaires radiologiques
bactériologiques nous on est vraiment
des formations très haut niveau les
fleurs industriels et autres donc des
sujets qui demande des grandes
compétences est ce que vous êtes ce
qu'on voit actuellement ce que
on voit défiler actuellement et qui
porte également le casque des
sapeurs-pompiers que vous avez pu noter
sur la brigade des sapeurs-pompiers de
paris avec quelques quelques
modifications mais qui sont donc des
personnes civiles si j'ose dire donc des
fonctionnaires de l'état et non pas des
militaires parce que rappelle ce défilé
militaire par ailleurs mais on pense aux
gens qui sont sur le terrain à
l'extérieur du pays alors qu'en fait il
y a on l'a vu depuis le début de ce de
cela énormément de troupes françaises
qui se trouvent des stocks qui avaient
reculé de process et me dire qu'ils
travaillent ici pas forcément pour sa
dette c'est aussi pour montrer la
diversité des opérations exactement des
opérations et donc le bloc que l'on voit
passer et représente le blog du
ministère de l'intérieur et donc tous
ces gens qui ne sont pas des militaires
mais qui sont les fonctionnaires en
charge de la sécurité des français sur
le territoire national et même si les
armes et emplissent plusieurs missions
de sécurité du territoire national
notamment pour la marine sur les
approches maritimes l'armée de l'air la
sécurité d'espacés aériens et l'armée
terre principalement sur l'opération
sentinelle la majeure partie de la
protection des français sur le
territoire national en temps de paix est
assurée par par les fonctionnaires de
l'état qui ne sont pas des militaires
c'est eux ce défilé est comme les autres
défilés dans fête est aussi symbolique
et il y avait un slogan qui était
choisie il faut tout pour faire une
armée c'est aussi ça il ya peut-être
dans l'imaginaire collectif peut-être le
militaire en première ligne avec le
fusil
et tout autour pour le soutenir pour
l'appuyer avec l'artillerie et avec les
chars avec la logistique avec
l'alimentation avec tous ces sujets avec
les financiers il faut vraiment de
différentes spécialités pour que au
final l'émission puissent être remplies
d'où cette représentativité un taux des
différents corps il en est de même pour
la sécurité et la défense nationale la
défense de l'avant donc plutôt
caractérisée par les militaires quand
ils sont projetés en opération
extérieure mais aussi comme disait le
commandant la défense d apprendre que la
défense du territoire et la sécurité du
territoire plat qui a illustré par ce
qu'on voit en face de nous si je me
trompe pas l'administration
pénitentiaire donc ceux qui s'occupent
dans les prisons mais c'est peut-être
plus paul enjeux relatifs les gardiens
de la prison qui s'occupe aussi de la
valse ce volet de sécurité qui nous
touche aussi tous alors nous demander
quand est-ce que passée la patrie de
fanta votre de france est déjà passée
vous pouvez les retrouver sur ce live
ils sont passés aux alentours de 10h45 à
peu près une heure ils sont passés
effectivement réussi à retrouver les
images des hélicoptères voilà ces
hélicoptères qui vont pas tarder à
défiler maintenant puisque il était
prévu à
11h31 exactement il était prévu il ya 10
minutes mais bon classique c'est
classique que ce les dernières vous de
retard de la lainière je me souviens il
y avait cinq six minutes
me mets à la base du militaire c'est de
s'adapter
s'il faut qu'il faut décaler
l'ensemble qui est pourtant très
imposants comme on le dit depuis ce
matin arrive à se recaler il ya des
petites minutes alors là on voit ce qui
normalement généralement à
l'applaudimètre sont aussi pas mauvais
il faudra peut-être se demander à votre
journaliste la légion étrangère avec
spécial une petite spécificité on vous
parlait donc des pionners queniez
derrière de la musique de la légion
étrangère et puis dernier derrière un
blu qui est peut-être plus exposés du 2e
régiment étranger de génie mais je vais
revenir sur les pionniers qui
appartiennent majoritairement au 1er
régiment étranger qui traditionnellement
regroupe les soldats les plus anciens de
la légion qui après avoir mené des
carrières opérationnel intense et
éreintante vont au 1er régiment étranger
qui est un régime en charge du soutien
des opérations et donc un petit peu
moins en première ligne mais pas
forcément et donc c'est ici que l'on
retrouve les les soldats les plus
expérimentés les plus anciens et donc
ceux qui comme l'a dit mme camara tout à
l'heure où le temps d'avoir la plus
longue barbe qu'est ce qui peut
expliquer ce que c'est je me trouvais à
progresser spéciale eh bien écoutez la
légion étrangère c'est une unité de
l'armée de terre française qui accueille
en son sein des gens de n'importe quelle
nationalité que ce soit puisque bien
évidemment dans toutes les autres unités
de l'armée française il faut être
français pour pouvoir pour pouvoir
servir et bien la légion étrangère à
cette spécificité
d'accueillir les étrangers quels qu'ils
soient après qu'ils aient passé
différents tests d'entrée notamment
physique mais aussi de contrôler tout de
même de passé judiciaire ou autres
puisque même si
on dit que la légion là tout le passé on
ne peut tout de même pas accepter
certains crimes au sein au sein de ces
unités est donc ce sont majoritairement
des étrangers mais vous avez aussi des
français qui peuvent choisir de servir
au sein de la de la légion étrangère qui
sont d'ailleurs très utile puisque
l'ensemble de ces étrangers ne parle pas
du tout français à son intégration et
donc les engagés français certes à
assurer la liaison si j'ose dire avec
leur leurs camarades et l'encadrement
landais première des premières années
mais pour avoir travaillé avec eux je
peux vous dire que des soldats qui
arrivent d'horizons aussi lointains que
l'extrême orient où l'amérique du sud où
l'afrique au bout de quelques années
parlent français sont capables de partir
sur des opérations complexes avec des
unités 100% française remplir leur
mission est d'ailleurs le régiment que
l'on verra tout à l'heure qui ferme la
marche de la légion étrangère le 2e
régiment étranger de génie que je
connais particulièrement bien puisque
c'est le régiment de génie de la brigade
de montagne et vous avez sur les rangs
notamment vous verrez en avant du bloc
les capitaines les commandants d'unités
il ya le capitaine ludovic que j'ai
connu alors qu'il était lieutenant qui
servait à la tête de sa section de génie
sous mes ordres
au mali il y a quelques années
voilà onze ans terré sur les tabliers en
le commandant parler que
de pionnière avec un certain une
certaine inexpérience on voit des
placards comme on dit donc des médailles
qui pour certains penchent à gauche
c'est à dire sous le poids de la
médaille on penche un peu sur le côté
c'est des marqueurs d'ancienneté mais
aussi des marqueurs du mérite et donc on
repérait ont repéré sur certains
tabliers des sous-officiers notamment
qui avait quelques années de service et
sans doute quelques missions et pas
forcément des missions très simple avec
des missions au feu et autres donc là on
voit là on voit cette l'ancienneté et
les élèves et les formes de 6 et ce pas
lents qui donne une forme de
tranquillité de la vieille la vieille
troupe qui avancent tranquillement
quoique sans se prendre la tête et en
avant on va retrouver timothée ddm qui
est tour sur les champs-elysées avec une
question qu'on à chaque année sur ce dvd
est ce que la légion étrangère a gagné à
l'applaudimètre
[Musique]
difficile de dire s'il allait jouer à
être j'en ai gagné à l'applaudimètre ce
qui est certain c'est qu'ils sont restés
pendant de longues minutes
stationner vraiment juste derrière nous
la 5 m 2 nous vous le voyez il était
juste derrière la sur le haut niveau de
la place clemenceau ils ont patienté
pendant de longues de longs instants
avant de enfin commencé leur défilé
tambour battant et dès qu'ils se sont
élancés effectivement pas mal
d'applaudissements qui sont qui sont
sortis la 2de voilà des travées de la
foule beaucoup d'applaudissements de là
à dire qu'ils ont été les plus applaudis
je ne peux pas me risquer je le disais
tout à l'heure la brigade des
sapeurs-pompiers de paris a elle été
très applaudie lorsqu'elle est passée en
tous les cas voilà l'ambiance qui ici
est monté petit à petit les jeux les
yeux parce qu'un hélicoptère vient de
passer juste juste au dessus de nous les
les unités qui ont été de plus en plus à
petit voilà au fur et à mesure du défilé
et voilà il a foulquier toujours amassés
au niveau des barrières on ne se lasse
pas les gens attendent étude du défilé
nous ici on voit pas mal de gyrophares
derrière dès lors on ne peut pas
distinguer qui skie qu'il s'agit vu
d'ici mais voilà des motos qui
s'apprêtait à passer devant nous et puis
surtout on disait les hélicoptères de
l'aviation légère de l'armée de terre
qui devrait arriver d'ici quelques
instants en tout cas c'est ce que la
foule attend à présent
me timothée effectivement merci beaucoup
les hélicoptères qui passe vous voyez
sur les images
pour marquer les 30 ans du commandement
des opérations spéciales donc le
commandement
qui gère toutes les opérations spéciales
deux hélicoptères de l'armée de l'air
d'un escadron qui est basé du côté de
bordeaux des hélicoptères donc qui ont
une double mission une mission de
sauvetage en mer mais surtout aussi une
mission de gérer les opérations
spéciales donc l'insertion des commandos
des forces spéciales donc ça fait 30 ans
que a été créé le commandement des
opérations spéciales une création qui a
été faite après la première guerre du
golfe ou au contact notamment des
américains et des anglais les français
se sont rendus compte qu'ils avaient
manqué peut-être un niveau qui
permettait d'intégrer toutes les
compétences toutes les capacités des
différentes armées toutes les
compétences spéciales des différentes
armées donc ce commandement très
particulier qui est là aussi souvent en
première ligne de toutes les dernières
opérations et donc ça fait 30 ans que ce
commandement a été créé pour les images
en direct qui vaut notre journaliste
jacques martin dans l'un des
hélicoptères il va passer justement au
dessus des champs elysées avant
l'allumage qui ils recommencent à figer
on vous explique tout à l'heure pourquoi
s'est elle tient l'ensemble des
hélicoptères que vous allez voir défiler
n'appartiennent pas tous à l'aviation
légère de l'armée de terre comme l'a dit
mon camarade il y en a également de
l'armée de l'air mais vous en verrez
aussi de la marine est bien évidemment
de la sécurité civile et de la
gendarmerie comme on le sait depuis
depuis ce matin vous avez normalement
actuellement au dessus de l'arc de
triomphe le bloc qui représente le sous
groupement aéro combat c'est à dire un
rassemblement d'hélicoptères que l'on
on envoie en opération qui était
actuellement déployés au mali sur la
base la base de gao composé d'un mélange
d'hélicoptères de transport qui permet
de transporter des troupes des commandos
ou d'autres et d'hélicoptères de combat
comme l'hélicoptère tigre ou les
hélicoptères gazelle qui sont plus axées
sur la reconnaissance pour notre juriste
est actuellement en train de passer au
niveau de la tour eiffel on la ville à
passer au dessus de l'arc de triomphe on
va voir son hélicoptère qui est un peu
plus tard les les hélicoptères de la
marine là avec le nh90 navale et des
dauphins sur les côtés
les hélicoptères c'est aussi comme les
avions assez rapide avec différentes nos
différentes bloc qui se succèdent et là
vous avez les hélicoptères de la
gendarmerie qui ils m'ont qui suivait
normalement donc dans les cannes il ya
notre notre envoyé notre envie celle qui
est dans l'un de ses hélicoptères il est
dans le premier et voilà donc alors là
l'image claude paris on voulait cliquer
mais voilà il était dans le premier de
ces hélicoptères et on rappelle la
protection civile qui devait participer
à cette à cette opération n'a pas pu si
vous avez regardé il y avait deux
dernières hélicoptère qui était rouge et
jaune de la sécurité civile dont
l'indicatif et dragons suivi du numéro
du département ceci en hommage aux
premiers hélicoptères de sécurité civile
aux états unis qui étaient des sikorski
dragonfly est donc en signe de tradition
l'indicatif de la sécurité civile du
drame alors les troupes motorisées il
faut que nous expliquer un peu servir
tout ça parce qu'on voit beaucoup de
blindés on voit beaucoup de troupes
motorisées faut savoir un peu à quoi ça
c'est déjà avant la voilà devant les
images à un ensemble
2 à moto mixant police et gendarmerie et
vous les voyez le long des routes
quelquefois c'est pas agréable mais
aussi peuvent faire de l'escort pour des
transplantations de coeur et des
missions qui sans doute sont plus
agréables et et autres pour nous et
voilà un ensemble mixte police
gendarmerie à moto et là aussi tenir une
moto à très basse vitesse je peux vous
dire c'est comme pour les chevaux c'est
un exercice très périlleux le sais pas
s'il ya des motards chez les
téléspectateurs devant mais c'est pas
une mince affaire d'être assis petite
vitesse on a eu quelques ratés
d'ailleurs j'essaie plus été l'an
dernier où il ya deux ans oui ça alors
est donc derrière vous pouvez voir les
premiers véhicules blindés de l'armée de
terre ce sont des véhicules blindés
légers alors il est normal de les voir
en tête car ce sont des véhicules qui
sont traditionnellement employée pour
faire de la reconnaissance de la
reconnaissance sur les opérations
extérieures et c'est sur ce genre de
véhicule que j'ai servi au mali
particulièrement donc des véhicules très
rustique très agile mais comme leurs
noms l'indiquent léger et donc
faiblement blindés et donc ils utilisent
leur agilité pour se prévenir des coups
des coups adverses et là vous voyez
passer actuellement
actuellement vous avez passé déjà voir
sur lesquels on pourra revenir un peu
plus tard puisque là où nous sommes
revenus sur les sur les vbl avec le
général de division gaulin qui ouvre le
défilé motorisé le commandent la
première division de l'armée de terre
française
et donc c'est lui qui a la charge du
défilé motorisé cette année les bébés
l'acousticien exactions et bien comme je
viens de le dire le vbl véhicules
blindés légers sierra faire de la
reconnaissance donc on est en tête
devant notre mission si j'ose dire en
parlant en tant qu'ancienne anciens
éclaireurs ces deux de trouver
l'adversaire de trouver son point faible
pour pouvoir permettre à nos éléments
plus lourds de tapé exactement à
l'endroit qui fait mal et aussi notre
mission est de détruire les autres
reconnaissances adverse de lui crever
les yeux ainsi si j'ose dire c'est donc
un combat très agile
très discret parce qu'on ne peut pas
s'exposer directement aux coups adverses
quand vous parlez d'élitiste on le guen
km heure par exemple alors l'agilité ce
n'est pas forcément la vitesse du
véhicule mais c'est plutôt sa capacité à
se mouvoir en milieu tout terrain ou à
se cacher derrière des petits murs ou
aux forêts ou ou collines épatant pas
tant la vitesse car sur les théâtres
d'opération on ne peut pas rouler très
vite là vous voyez les véhicules griffon
véhicule gris font donc y sont les
véhicules du programme scorpion qui
arrive au sein de de l'armée terres déjà
plusieurs centaines de déployer au sein
de l'armée de terre ces véhicules ont
été déployés au mali cette année au sein
d'un groupement d'un groupement tactique
et donc mettre en oeuvre le programme
scorpion vous avez actuellement donc les
jaguars 4 jaguar ce sont c'est la
première fois qu'ils défilent sur les
champs elysées tout simplement parce
qu'ils viennent d'arriver au sein de
l'armée de terre française au sein du
1er régiment de chasseurs d'afrique qui
se charge de former les équipages à
l'utilisation des véhicules blindés et
donc ces véhicules ont vocation à
remplacer les amx 10 rc qui sont des
véhicules blindés véhicules canons des
chars moyens si j'ose dire sur lesquels
j'ai aussi servi en tant que cavalier
est intéressant de noter c'était un des
jaguars s'appelle ait ailleurs reçu un
nom de baptême le sergent blasco donc
qui est connu c'est ce ce chasseur alpin
qui a eu une carrière assez exceptionnel
tués au mali il ya quelques mois de ça
après avoir sauvé un équipages
d'hélicoptères et à avoir dans une
manoeuvre assez périlleuse en
l'accrochant
en l'accrochant un autre hélicoptère et
sur les roues et se sont envolés pour
sortir du feu de l'ennemi et puis il est
tombé au feu au combat quelques mois
plus tard repartant au combat après une
riche mais extrêmement intense carrière
et donc voilà une figure
comme ça qui a pris qui a donné le nom à
son son chat un an jean donc c'est un
tradition qui est répandu au sein des
armées de ne pas les oublier ce souvenir
est donc là vous voyez défiler le 126e
régiment d'infanterie donc sur ces
véhicules griffon dont je parlais tout à
l'heure qui ont vocation à remplacer les
vab de l'infanterie au motorisée de
l'armée de terre française et vous voyez
en arrière-plan arrivée des véhicules
blindés un peu plus lourds qui sont les
bbc y donc véhicules blindés de combat
d'infanterie qui eux sont des véhicules
blindés plus lourd avec un canon plus
gros mais qui transportent tout de même
des des fantassins pour combattre peu
ont pour vocation à combattre aux côtés
des chars leclerc et donc il s'agit du
segment lourde là vous voyez défiler des
éléments particuliers ce sont les
lance-roquettes unitaire donc ce sont
des éléments d'artillerie qui sont
déployés au niveau de la division et qui
lancent des roquettes à plus de 70 km
avec une précision métrique donc c'est
ce que l'on appelle de l'artillerie dans
la profondeur donc on n'a pas deux mais
pas de missiles mais en outre les tirs
des roquettes exactement à monter à
gallician navigation sur les sur les
régiments d'infanterie qui sont des
véhicules oui tout à fait puisque
l'infanterie même si à la fin des fins
elle combat débarquer elle se déploie
elle doit aller jusqu'à la zone de
combat pour pouvoir combattre et donc
elle est forcément en véhicules blindés
pour être protégé jusqu'à ce qu'elle
puisse débarquer au plus près de
l'adversaire donc les bbc i le rôle du
vb cic vraiment de rentrer dans la
défense adverse dans les champs de mines
les barbelés au milieu du combat et de
libérer ces fantassins qui partent
directement au combat dans les lignes de
défense adverse pour accompagner les
chars leclerc je salue veulent pas ou
nicole charles qu'ils soient qui sont
avec nous très beau défilé nous
différons n'hésitez pas à poser vos
questions alors qu'on voit apparaître la
un système d'artillerie qui commence à
avoir une petite réputation depuis
quelques mois maintenant puisqu'il a été
envoyé en l'ukraine un don de la france
que l'on dit que l'a fait la france aux
forces du craignait donc le césar qu'on
voyait apparaître là on voyait
apparaître à l'écran des vedettes du
génie pour faire du combat voilà le
césar lacombe dont je vous parlais avec
ce système sur un calme un camion donc
très mobiles mais également très précis
avec un canon derrière donc qui est
capable d'envoyer 30 40 kilomètres des
obus avec là aussi une grande précision
et de tirer rapidement de remballer le
matériel est d'aller se cacher pour
éviter ce qu'on appelle le tir de contre
batterie donc le des artilleurs adverses
qui identifie de douces à vienne et qui
renvoie en riposte d oggy donc voilà des
lru
dont parlait le commandant juste avant
c'est à dire que le saisir ces cas-là
césar on peut tirer et partir tout de
suite si coup en une minute et en moins
de trois minutes derrière le canon à rob
et le canon et rbc ont les équipages ont
retourné à l'intérieur ils sont capables
d'être à plusieurs centaines de mètres
et donc quand le coup arrive il ya plus
qu arrive là où dix estiment que ces
partis ils ne sont plus là donc c'est
cette extrême mobilité qui est
aujourd'hui recherché et qui a priori
fait des merveilles dans les combats qui
sont actuellement menées en ukraine là
vous voyez des éléments du 19è régiment
du génie donc qui représente ses moyens
de franchissement vous voyez les gros
les gros véhicules à l'arrière avec les
les boudins sur les côtés donc ce sont
des moyens de franchissement qui
permettent de franchir les fleuves ou
les rivières et bien pour nos troupes
blindées juste devant les éléments de
franchissement vous voyez trois blindés
3 blindé à chenilles donc qui sont des
engins blindés du génie dont la vocation
est d'effectuer le déminage dans les
zones les plus durs donc déminage sous
le feu adverse et déminage des zones les
plus dangereuses puisque sinon nos
soldats du génie sont capables de
déminer eux mêmes à pied en combattant
débarquer mais l'on comprend bien que
dans les zones les plus dangereuses on
envoie nos engins blindés alors on à une
question d'un internaute c'est ce que le
canon de ligue aubeterre tigre suis
vraiment l'oeil du pilote oui il ya un
système ayant s'appelle à servir le
canon au casque du pilote donc quand le
pilote de tourner la tête le il ya un
mois il ya moyen que c'est pas le pilat
d'ailleurs c'est le chef de bord il a
moyen d'aligner le pis le canon avec
avec avec son skill voirie c'est un
système et c'est un caban qui tire à
plusieurs kilomètres plusieurs
kilomètres et qui donc rentrée difficile
l'identification de l'hélicoptère alors
qu'il tire sur un sur un adversaire
parce que lorsque l'hélicoptère est à
plusieurs kilomètres on peut croire que
ce n'est pas lui qui est en train de
nous de nous tirer dessus mais est donc
lui faire profiter d'éventuelles
faiblesses le lot 6 essais des véhicules
assez léger alors là aussi là c'est
symbolique de ce qu'ils appellent de un
groupement de recherche multi capteurs
donc c'est à dire la recherche
d'informations de renseignements par
différents moyens donc on a vu des quads
tout au début donc des équipes très
agile très rapide qui sont capables
d'aller déterminer où l adversaire il y
avait aussi des drones qui étaient tirés
via des petits véhicules blindés pour
avoir des du renseignement d'origine
image donc des photos des captures et
puis là il ya en voile et les vagues qui
sont dus de la guerre électronique donc
c'est à dire déterminer où sont les
signaux adverse rentrée devant dedans
éventuellement les décrypter les
brouiller leur faire perdre la tête donc
voilà donc c'est ce groupement de
recherche multi capteurs qui prend à la
fois des du renseignement d'origine
humaine d'origine image elle est
d'origine électronique qui synthétise
tout ça pour donner à une vision la plus
complète possible au commandement du
dispositif à lui émis puis après pour
ensuite éventuellement appliquer les
feux ou en tout cas choisir la manoeuvre
voilà donc c'est le renseignement ne se
fait pas juste comme au cinéma ou par là
de la voix ou par la conversation dans
une image souvent c'est cette synthèse
qui fait la plus value et qui apporte
une réelle compétence et une
compréhension fine de la situation c'est
ce que l'on appelle des multiplicateurs
d'efficacité multiplicateur de force et
donc pour en avoir eu quelques éléments
sous mes ordres notamment au mali je
peux vous dire que leur leur apport est
vraiment essentiel est essentielle dans
l'analyse de la situation où la
découverte du plan adverse avant même
qu'ils ne sachent que l'on est capable
de l'écouter ou de le voir alors on est
une publication de nicole 06 qui ne
demandent quel est le pourcentage de
matériel français dans les différentes
d'armé
alors écoutez je pense que pour l'armée
de terre et les unités dans lesquelles
j'ai servi on est à bien plus de 90% de
matériel français un temps nos blindés
que nos transmissions que nos différents
équipements munitions et autres et
finalement c'est une partie somme toute
secondaire pour - au moins pour nous
dans l'armée de terre qui vient qui
vient de l'étrange ma voix là pour
donner un ordre d'idée par exemple tous
les tous les avions de chasse qui ont
volé son été construit par dassault
aviation pour pas les citer il faut
faire les astérix en disant qu'ils sont
actionnaires du figaro je crois sur
cette maison pour les hélicoptères qui
ont défilé c'est quasi exclusivement des
hélicoptères airbus hélicoptères qui ont
été construits à marignane du côté de
marseille pour les camions de l'armée de
terre on va avoir énormément d'anciens
renault
deux sociétés comme marcus comme nexter
donc des sociétés françaises qui
assemble produisent et développe en
france là vous voyez typiquement pour la
brigade de sapeurs pompiers vous avez un
croisillon sûr sûr sûr les camions
significatif et symbolique aussi d'une
société française donc voilà il ya une
comme le disait le commande comment dans
les matériels étrangers et il y en a il
y aurait pu avoir le drones reaper
d'origine américaine mais c'est plus
secondaires voilà que que majoritaire
est-ce que les chevaux sont français
alors oui même normand souvent
généralement il ya une
il ya une filière où ils sont choisis
chaque année et autres selon leur
potentiel est donc une moi une grande
majorité des chevaux qui viennent de
normandie et qui d'ailleurs après leur
leur temps il passe une retraite
paisible donc il ya des arbres là
notamment en normandie qui récupère des
chevaux de la gendarmerie de la garde
républicaine
alors là nous sommes dans l'hélicoptère
qui est qui ramène ce coloriste julien
leclercq a la base je sais pas sur
quelle base il va se poser du lac où bhl
elle a priori il repart à villa qu'on
m'avait dit qu'il a fait est là on voit
la base de villacoublay villacoublay qui
accueille à la fois là les forces
aériennes de la gendarmerie comme le
disait mais aussi les escadrons qui
s'occupe du transport des hautes
autorités
militaires donc avec des falcons des
appareils plus lourds donc une base
située dans le 78 qui voit là où même le
groupement d'intervention d'hélicoptères
donc ceux qui fournissent les
hélicoptères pour le gign et le raid
pour être déployé le plus rapidement
possible sur les zones de crise la prise
d'otages la leyre pts
une situation terroriste donc ils sont
basés pas très loin de la base du ggn et
la baisse dur est donc une belle de
villacoublay king qui est
particulièrement utile dans le
dispositif de couverture du territoire
français voire même à l'international
pour certains
certaines missions alors on va revenir
là sur ce défilé qui surfait type se
termine qui nous parlait pas de jaux
exactement il se termine par le défilé
des troupes montées de régiment de
cavalerie de la garde républicaine
alors en tant que cavalier même si
aujourd'hui nous servons plus sur des
chevaux mais servant sur des chars et
des engins blindés
comme vous l'avez vu c'est toujours un
moment particulier de voir défiler une
troupe monte à cheval et notamment la
musique la musique à cheval de la garde
républicaine qui a gardé les hymnes qui
était jouée à l'époque où les troupes
combattent et encore à cheval et qui
donc leur permettait de garder le rythme
lorsqu'elles s'étaient lancées à la
bataille face à leurs adversaires alors
hélicoptère sur lequel nous étions et ne
veut pas se poser vous rappelle que le
but lui aussi concédé copé a relancé de
surveiller des routes
[Musique]
ces différentes missions on à la
gendarmerie
d'appui aux populations donc typiquement
dans les inondations dans le sud de la
france hier il ya quelques temps il
avait était allé chercher en appui avec
l'hélicoptère de la sécurité civile des
personnes qui étaient sur les toits il
ya aussi la reconnaissance de départs
d'incendiés qui sont faits mais aussi
d'aider par exemple d'aider les tracts
pour des personnes qui suite à des
meurtres et autres sont à rechercher
tout ça donc différentes missions alors
panel l'émission très là on va l'essayer
volé les images de l'atterrissage
m
répondez en tout
[Rires]
[Musique]
parfait
les brawn année pour leur langue
les bons
transpondeur
girard et leurs pions n'est pas lui
[Musique]
motore le sourire de sortir au toit
dehors des vacances mais parade
les arriérés
on n'a pas eu ça n'a pas trop la vache
n'est pas encore très bien quand il faut
pas vraiment mauvaise dans la nuit
on est rentré avec plusieurs choses
écrit sur les formes
un post permis toujours bien
contre leur gré
semir papier aussi derrière
[Musique]
au caire il nous restera de
blé pour le retour
donc il a mieux terminé alors qu'il va
pouvoir tourner être connus début
du défilé puisque la pl partie
gelé les chevaux les troupes montées ont
terminé de deux dvi c'est ce qui
habituellement fini défilé où ça peut
changer ça alors écoutez je n'ai pas le
jeu n'est pas le l'historique mais je
pense que traditionnellement c'est bien
les troupes montées les troupes montées
qui ferme le défilé ne seraient
peut-être que pour des questions
logistiques dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure puisque plus on augmente le
nombre de chevaux qui passe avant les
troupes à pied plus le défilé est
difficile pour eux
[Musique]
une animation de
clôture on va qu'on va vivre
mais un moment festif de
défendue dé
femmes défilent et qui là aussi a
vocation à passer un message cette année
c'est sur l'excellence académique et
sportive
[Musique]
des forces de défense et de sécurité
pour la laisser vivre ces images où les
mettre en plein écran avec la musique
qu'il est président
là
[Musique]
le
[Applaudissements]
la bâloise
[Musique]
oui en tout
oh la la
[Musique]
gt on
m
[Musique]
oui
je
la montée est parue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chance d ivoire veut toujours plus haut
dans l'histoire et toulon claque comme
un rappeur c'est la fête ce gars rapides
l'infanterie et partout là où et de
de gaulle sur les champs-elysées
c'est le sens
qu'il veut voir trouble herman cl est
qui s'attirent surtout l'horizon
cellulaire
c'est l'horreur conseiller et puissant
et
engagé
oui donc
on
et
là
et m
c'est marianne il se dessine
c'est une amie qui vient nous sauver
jours
notre quoi
jamais de feu vert
c'est ça
oui
et pour des coûts
vital
gagner tous les jours
il
c'est
l'état
super
c'est
les hommes
le pr
mais je
oui
m
le oh
vous
et là bas
[Musique]
voilà on vient entendre qu'en 12 paris
une chanteuse qui est une création
musicale originale pour ce pour cette
forme 14 juillet est la chanson je
chante et france et on va écouter et oui
la marseillaise
[Musique]
ah non ce n'est pas encore la
marseillaise
le tableau
française avec le
france qui est réalisé par des élèves
des lycées militaires
des écoles le prytanée national
militaire ça
saint cyr l'école la légion d'honneur
pour repère à sa ceinture les jeunes
filles qu'avec leur ceinture de la
légion d'honneur des
lycées eux
d'éducation qui sont défendues
faire désarmer donc ça c'est pour
l'excellence académique et puis de
vendre nous nous voyons l'excellence
sportive donc ce sont
militaires des sportifs sous contrat
avec le ministère des armées qui
qui réalise une carrière militaire alors
ce qui est très intéressant l'iowa en
fauteuil roulant ça c'est un blessé de
l'arthrite rca commandos parachutistes
de l'air assez connue qui fait du kayak
en compétition
avec la
carrière militaire c est la semaine
c'est malheureux car ayant fait
rationnel qui malheureusement s'est
arrêté suite à une blessure au mali avec
des fois une invitation aux gens mais il
a continué en disant
c'est pas parce que je suis blessé que
je dois je dois m'arrêter tout est donc
il mène aujourd'hui une carrière de très
très très haut niveau sur le plan
sportif
récupère en
gagnant en remportant un grand nombre de
compétitions notamment aux olympiques
paralympiques et donc sa voix lasse et
ont favorisé cette excellence sportive
des militaires 2 les militaires il y
avait d'autres laissés sur les rangs ici
qui à la fois pour se reconstruire et
aussi pour
continuer est passé
ce moment compliqué de leur vie selon
dans cette carrière
ils ont contre nous de la tyrannie
et ont
ensanglanté le vert et on à l'ars
entendez-vous dans les campagnes mugir
ces féroces soldats
ils viennent juste
[Musique]
montag
non
chez
marché
bien
en somme
attention
le bas
non
le son
on sent
à
sinon on
[Musique]
liberté
m
[Musique]
des français
on va
les blés et ben ça
sous nos drapeaux
du poids à
au latéral laffont
entre temps m ils assureront en tant qu
en
moi
là
et
[Musique]
là
voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
et
du coup
mais
[Musique]
mo
à
sow
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà que vous devez suivre cette
marseillaise 7 7 mars plusieurs couples
et on va tout autre le timothée timothy
qu'avec un élève de l'école
polytechnique
timothée c'est amis
oui vincent avec un étudiant de l'école
polytechnique marquez qui est en
première année appelé teddy que vous
avez
défilé pour la première fois de votre
vie sur les champs elysées il ya
quelques instants on imagine que c'est
un grand honneur pour vous effectivement
c'était la première fois c'est très
impressionnant de voir tout ce monde
rassemblait notamment les avions qui
sont passés au dessus de nous avant
qu'on est fils
effectivement c'est vraiment très
impressionnant le bruit que ça fait et
tout ce monde rassemblé avec tout le
public sur les côtés qui applaudit qui a
applaudi quand on est passé racontez
nous un petit peu comment tout ça s'est
déroulé on imagine déjà que ça fait un
certain temps que vous vous préparez à
ce défilé effectivement ça fait environ
dix jours qu'on se prépare à satory donc
avec une piste qui reproduit un petit
peu celle des champs-elysées et il ya
des des hauts gradés militaires qui nous
qui nous surveillent qui nous film afin
de s'assurer que on est bien aligné que
les bras sont bien coordonnées etc donc
c'est un travail assez lent
effectivement cette journée là comment
elle s'est déroulée on imagine déjà que
vous êtes arrivé assez tôt comment est
ce que vous vous êtes préparé
aujourd'hui pour se défiler alors en
fait on est parti à 5h45 de l'école
polytechnique à palaiseau et on est
arrivés en car vers vers 6h 6h30 7h et à
partir de là ça a été le passage d'abord
général qui a revu les troupes puis du
président macron et jusqu'à environ
10h40 pour notre passage il pour défiler
sur les champs-elysées un petit mot
peut-être sur votre sur votre uniforme
je vois que vous porter par exemple des
gants blancs est ce que vous pouvez nous
nous décrire un petit peu cet uniforme
donc des étudiants de polytechnique
alors je dirais que ce qui est important
dans l'uniforme c'est notamment le
bicorne tiéti ci comporte pencher sur le
sourcil droit
puisque on a une cérémonie pour nous
remettre au début de l'année et on a
aussi la tangente donc l'épée comporte
parallèle au corps on va essayer de la
de la montre et là effectivement à
l'écran voilà donc cet ep i racontez
nous un petit peu que qu'est ce qu'est
ce qu'elle représente elle représente
l'école polytechnique puisqu'on est la
seule à avoir on est la seule école
avoir cet ep particulièrement il ya le
le symbole de l'école sur le sur le foro
et effectivement on la porte
contrairement aux autres officiers de
l'armée de terre parallèle au corps donc
c'est pour ça qu'on appelle la tangente
et puis les gants blancs effectivement
pour les événements comme celui
d'aujourd'hui effectivement les gants
blancs mais ça c'est assez commun à
toute l'armée toute l'armée de terre en
général merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le
temps de vous arrêter pour débriefer on
va dire ce ce défilé du 14 juillet voilà
et puis vincent et bien comme vous
l'imaginez les champs-elysées qui sont
en train de se de se vider derrière moi
là vous le voyez la foule qui a
totalement disparu les gens qui ont
commencé à partir aussitôt après la fin
de ce défilé dès que la la garde
républicaine et est repassé devant nous
les gens ont commencé à repartir je
rappelle que certains sont arrivés très
tôt ce matin à l'image de marque qui lui
a été du côté du cortège mais enfin les
spectateurs certains sont arrivés dès 6h
6h30 du matin et donc ils sont partis
assez rapidement à la fin de ceux de ce
défilé militaire
très bien mou merci beaucoup timothée
merci beaucoup on va peut-être juste
voir un peu ces images du président de
la république qui salue les médaillés
olympiques qui font partie de l'armée et
voilà en train de saluer il il a aussi
remercié la chanteuse on l'a vu avec les
origines d'un cran la chanteuse qui a
institué ce titre france candice parise
on va te retourner du côté de julien
leclercq julien leclercq qui nous a fait
vivre ce défilé à bord d'un hélicoptère
de la gendarmerie
julien leclercq vous êtes je crois avec
le pilote de votre hélicoptère on va
vous laisser l'interviewer
oui bonjour alors je suis avec
jean-françois gaucherie qui est colonel
de la gendarmerie alors monsieur
gaucherie c'était comment ce défilé déjà
eh bien c'était magnifique ont été
extrêmement fiers d'avoir défilé avec
tous nos camarades du ministère de
l'intérieur et des armes est évidemment
et c'est une très belle journée pour
tout le monde est-ce que l'exercice a
été réussie pour moi c'est un exercice
réussi puisque il faut savoir qu'on nous
demande de passer avec une précision de
trois secondes sur la tribune et on est
passé à la seconde près donc on est
content de ce résultat et on espère
avoir été vos depuis le sol d'accord
qu'est ce qui
rend unique le rôle de pilote
d'hélicoptère au sein de tout ce
dispositif et bien finalement on est on
déjà c'est un travail d'équipé puisqu'il
n'y a pas que des pilotes il ya aussi
évidemment des contrôleurs le ce jour j
puisqu'il ya énormément de d'aéronefs en
l'air donc le niveau de coordination est
très élevé et donc nous on est un des
maillons de la chaîne évidemment un
maillon qu'on voit souvent mais
évidemment pas le seul puisque les
mécaniciens prépare nos machines et les
contrôleurs vérifient nos trajectoires
d'accord et qu'est ce qui rend le
pilotage d'un hélicoptère
différent des avions qu'on a pu voir
lors du défilé qu'est ce que c'est une
question de sensations ou lorsqu'on
pilote est ce qu'on ressent plus la
machine comment ça se passe alors je
dirais qu'il ya un peu de magie dans
l'hélicoptère puisque ne serait ce que
sur le haut niveau
scientifique on va dire autant modéliser
ce qui se passe sur un avion maintenant
on arrive à le faire à peu près bien
autant sur un hélicoptère il reste une
part de mystère et cette magie c'est
vraiment quelque chose que je trouve
fantastique et pouvoir soulever une
telle masse à travers une commande est
resté en stationnaire c'est quelque
chose d'incroyable c'est ce qui vous a
frappé la première fois que vous avez
vraiment commencé à piloter des
hélicoptères ah oui c'est vraiment ce
côté magique de de rester en
stationnaire dans les airs de déjà deux
volets c'est déjà extraordinaire mais de
pouvoir voler sur place comme le font
certains oiseaux je trouve ça
merveilleux vous préparé depuis combien
de temps pour se défiler toute l'année
j'imagine alors le défilé en fait on
vole toute l'année régulièrement donc
c'est on s'entraîne globalement appui au
pilotage toute l'année après le défilé à
proprement parler on a quelques quelques
répétitions dédié avant mais finalement
ce n'est que le reflet d'un travail
qu'on fait au quotidien et d'émissions
j'imagine extrêmement complexe vous
intervenez dans quel type de contexte
principalement alors ce qui est
passionnant gendarmerie c'est que on a
un contexte très vaste les missions sont
extrêmement variés il ya évidemment tout
ce qui est
sécurité publique générale ont fait
également un petit peu de secours par
subsidiarité de nos camarades de la
sécurité civile on est on est employé
vraiment dans différentes différents
domaines et dans tous les milieux ce
soit en plein en bande côtière en
montagne l'action la gendarmerie de
toute façon elle et elle est valable
partout et nous sommes un moyen d'appui
donc nous sommes vraiment là pour
appuyer nos camarades au sol on ne se
suffisait à nous mêmes on est là au